- Meilyne is like
terrified of male nipples.
- No, it's 'cause when you
don't wanna stare at something
but then you just end up looking.
And I just feel like-
- Continue, continue.
- It's staring into my soul
and I just feel uncomfortable.
- In other words, you
don't stare at the nipple,
the nipple stares you back.
(all laughing)
- Yes.
(bright upbeat music)
- Hello my fellow Sigma males
and welcome to "Trash Taste."
- Yeah.
- I'm with my usual fellow Sigma males,
Connor and Joey.
- Hello.
- And we are with our mum,
Meilyne, maker of the boys.
- What?
(Mae laughing)
- She birthed us from her mind vagina.
(all laughing)
- what?
- We were just discussing
this and we were like,
"Should we just bring Meilyne back on?"
"Yeah, we should have Meilyne back."
- How many episodes has
it been since you were on?
You were on like episode six or something?
Or episode seven, something like that?
- I don't know, something like
the first 10 continuously.
- You were like one
of the first, yeah.
- It was like 60 episodes ago
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- You're the only person
who's been on "Trash Taste"
that has not signed the shit to sheet.
So we gotta change that now.
- We're always here.
- She signs our checks,
that's why.
- Yeah, yeah.
(all laughing)
I do, I do.
- She gives us her signature every month.
(men laughing)
- So we thought we'd mix
things up this episode
and I guess bring on our manager
and I guess get a female
perspective of things, right?
- A female perspective?
- Yeah.
How do females sound
derogatory when you say it?
Doesn't it sound, people who say females,
they're like, "Females."
Would you do like it when someone
refers to you as a female?
- Like I'm indifferent.
- Ah okay.
- I don't want to say what.
- I've had people who've been like.
- Do you hate being called a male?
- I've had friends.
- Or that male over there.
(men laughing)
- Sigma male. Sigma male.
(all laughing)
- Sigma male.
- I've had friends who've been like,
"Oh female sounds so like incel-y,
or like derogatory."
- Oh yeah, I think it depends on the tone.
- They're like, "Females."
- The tone you say it.
- Yeah.
- It's the hard 'fe?', isn't it?
(Connor laughing)
fe-male.
- I've had friends who've said it.
- I don't think the word itself,
if you're just like, "Yo, female."
(all laughing)
"How's it going?"
- Yeah, that's offensive.
- Hello, my fellow females.
(all laughing)
- Hey yo female.
- I've watched a lot
of anime, oh not anime,
animal videos on YouTube.
So they're like, "Oh, this female Badger."
So I'm like.
- Yeah but no one goes "this
female human over here".
- Would be kind of weird to be like
this woman Badger like that.
(all laughing)
- I think that's just
for humans. (laughing)
- This lady badger.
(all laughing)
- Although, in child nature shows.
I think they say girls
and boys, don't they?
- The girl badger.
- Yeah, like the girl badger
- Aw yeah, I think it depends.
- I think for like newborns.
Right?
- Yeah.
- And then I guess when they reach of age,
I don't even know what that is.
When they're an adult,
they're just male and female, (laughs)
but I've never thought about this deeply.
- Well because boy and girl
kind of sounds more like infant.
- We're getting really into it now.
- Yeah, yeah.
(all laughing)
- Whereas like you're not
gonna point to a baby and go
"That female over there".
- You would say that baby.
- But, if you were to specify which baby,
you would say, "The girl baby,
or the girl".
- You would just say
that little girl.
- Or whatever the baby
identifies as.
- Yeah, that little girl,
right? You don't say that little female.
(man laughs)
- I don't know.
- What are we talking about?
- I don't even know what
we're talking about.
- I think it's because it's after dinner,
you guys are full and it's just like.
- Don't date this.
(men laughing)
Don't tell them when we record.
(all laughing)
I don't want them to know.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- I don't want them to
know our eating habits
and our recording habits.
Jesus Meilyne!
- Oh! Oh!
I don't know, it's just sitting up there.
- What's the strangest thing
you've seen one of us do?
(all laughing)
- No pressure.
- Just wondering, let's keep this going.
- Yeah, because I feel
Meilyne's perspective of weird
is very different to the average female.
(all laughing)
- You just said female!
- Wow! Woo Joey! Joey!
- Joey!
- The hard f! Jesus shit!
- Okay.
Let's just-
- [Men] Female.
- Oh my God! What a terrible start?
(all laughing)
- Do you have something in
mind or do you wanna say it?
- Okay. Okay.
- Okay.
- Well the most recent stuff is the stuff
that comes to mind.
I don't even watch you
guys record that much.
So I'm like upstairs,
recently.
- Yeah.
- Well, it doesn't have to be on camera.
- Oh okay.
- Yeah, 'cause I would
say like definitely,
recording "Trash Taste" has
made me more self-conscious,
and also hanging out with Meilyne
has made me a little
self-conscious as well.
- I don't say, what?
- No, sometimes I'll just
do something subconsciously.
Like for example,
I'll be sitting there and
I'll have my hand in my sock,
you know? (laughs)
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Which just happened like 1/2
an hour ago and she was like-
- I wouldn't say.
Let's see, it's not weird.
What is cute?
When Sydney, calls you "Little Babyman!"
(all laughing)
It's like dinners, sorry!
- I used to do it with my boy.
(all laughing)
- Oh my God!
- I love it so much!
- The sigma male energy
just escapes out the window.
(all laughing)
- Like we're eating dinner.
- Not in front of the
camera Mae Lin, Jesus!
- Am I allowed to say this?
- (laughing) Just kidding.
- Well you've said it now.
- She said it now.
- We're at dinner, like
it was Thanksgiving,
and then Sydney was like,
"Oh it's my little baby".
And then Garnt. I thought
Garnt's like this.
- It is like when your mom is like,
"I hope my little boy is doing well".
- But out of nowhere he
starts blushing like,
(all laughing)
and I'm just like,
"Wow! Sydney's got it under control."
- She is my fucking mum, isn't she?
She's just trying to fucking
embarrass me right now Jesus!
(Garnt laughing)
No, because I feel like Sydney,
Sydney started saying that
I just like to piss me off
and then like-
- You don't look pissed off.
- Does it piss you off?
- You know when you're
in a group of friends,
right?
(Meilyne laughing)
And then you say something ironically,
and then you start saying
something ironically,
and then you keep doing it.
And then it becomes un-ironic, right.
(Joey laughing)
- Baby boy.
- No, baby man. No Baby man.
(all laughing)
- That's worse.
- No because that came from
just a random fucking video.
'Cause I remember when Joey
used to fucking dab everywhere,
I was like, "Joey, can you stop
fucking dabbing everywhere."
- Yeah.
- And then I started doing
it and I'm just like,
"I fucking hate Joey."
- You did use to dab all the time.
- Yeah. Because I made it my life mission.
I think it was like 2016, 2017,
I told myself at the
beginning of that year.
I'm like, "I'm gonna
use a social experiment.
Every photo I upload
of myself of that year,
I need to be dabbing.
And I'm just gonna see if I can fulfill
that just to see how far I can get."
- Did you do it?
- I did it.
- No way.
On every single photo?
- Yeah.
- Every photo of me in 2017, I'm dabbing.
- Why would you do that?
- Because it's hilarious.
- I'm not laughing.
- Because seeing the comments.
Because all of the angry
comments of people being like,
"Why are you doing this?"
It was just funny to me.
- Yeah. But at which point
did it stop becoming ironic,
that you just ended up doing it?
'Cause that definitely
did reach that point.
- I think after maybe
the second time I did it,
(all laughing)
I was like, "Oh, this is kind of fun."
- I did think there was a
year that you did dab a lot.
That was probably the year, then.
- Yeah, that was probably
the year we met actually.
- That was like 2016,
2017 right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- What an awful first impression?
But like, I feel you're
very heavily influenced
by the people around you in that sense.
'Cause like recently in
that same sense, right?
Like you started dabbing unironically
after I kept doing it.
- You dabbed?
- No.
(all laughing)
- Oh you dabble?
- Like you dabble in the dab?
- You dabbed?
- Oh for fuck sake, shut up.
- But then on this fucking podcast, right?
Like I'm very known to the
saying, I fuck with this.
And then Garnt started saying
that unironically as well.
- What can I say if you hang
out with your homies enough?
- You also say a hundred percent.
(all laughing)
- A hundred percent.
- 100%. (laughing)
- Sometimes it echoes in my head.
Like after recording I go
home walking to the train,
"A hundred percent".
(all laughing)
- It's living rent free in your brain.
- Sure there are matrix in sync.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you guys are always in sync.
- If one of us is doing something,
the other is just programmed to do it.
- I don't think Garnt does
stuff that rubs off on you.
I feel like it's only
you rubbing off on Garnt.
(Meilyne laughing)
- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
(all laughing)
- No, no.
- You just hang out
with your homies enough
and I guess you just start
to mirror each other.
- Yeah, but I hang out with
you a lot but I still sip
like a normal human being.
(Connor laughing)
- I mean that's just me.
- I don't fucking sign up that shit right?
- I don't know why I sip like that.
I think it's the sippy cups,
that I just can't sip
like a normal human being.
I don't fucking know.
- Yeah, it does make you feel like a baby.
I feel like a dummy sometimes
drinking out of that.
- A little baby man?
- Yeah.
(Meilyne laughing)
(all laughing)
- I'm gonna find the original
video that's based on that
but one thing I do want
to talk about Meilyne,
is the viewers don't know this but,
you are like one of the most prolific,
Google reviewers in Japan.
Right?
- Used to be.
- Used to be? Okay.
- I would say,
three or four years ago.
- Well, who dethroned you? (laughs)
- I just stopped.
- What were you like?
What was your highest
rank, of food reviews?
- Not high.
- Master?
- It's like high was a contributor
or something like top 5% or something.
- Wow.
- And it gives you a
different score every month.
- See, I didn't even know you had scores.
- I didn't know that either.
- Did they pay you?
- No.
- Did you just just do
it for like the cloud?
- No, it's just-
- No, she does it for the prestige.
- I do it for the badges.
- What do you get for the badges?
- Like it just says, "Oh,
you're a novice or novice."
- She literally does
it for the Xbox cheats.
- So you literally play
"Pokemon Go" just in real life.
- Yeah.
(Joe laughing)
- But with like restaurants and stuff.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- To be fair whenever Meilyne's
recommended me a restaurant,
it's normally very good.
- It's usually pretty good.
- Yeah.
- If I've eaten there.
- I'll go there and I'll feel
like, "Wow! This is amazing."
And Meilyne's like, "Yeah, I'd
give it a three out of five."
And I'm like, "What?"
- (laughing) Yeah. Every time we go to,
we can't go to a restaurant
with Meilyne anymore
and have her enjoy her meal
because every time we're there,
I can see the cogs turning,
in her brain.
- You just don't ask me.
You just don't look at me
while I'm eating instead.
- I can't help it.
It's like, "Yeah, it's
super fascinating watching
your thought processes
as you eat this food."
- I really enjoy food but
I do just eat it very fast.
- You do, like you are
someone who eats food so fast
that I don't know how you can enjoy it.
- Do you have weekday eating
mode and weekend eating mode?
- What the fuck does that mean? (laughs)
- No speed in which you consume
the food.
- I agree. I agree.
But also when I think
I'm eating this too fast,
and then I slow down with
like my chewing or whatever,
I'm like, "It doesn't
really taste any better."
(Joey laughing)
- It just makes me more full.
- Does it?
- Yeah.
- And the slower you eat,
the more full you get.
- The slower you eat
the more full you get. Yeah.
It's because it takes a
certain amount of time
for your stomach's
processor and for a signal
to get sent to your brain
that says, "Hi, I'm full."
So if you actually eat slower,
then it's just a much more
natural way to eat less
because then you'll get full much faster.
- I think if I'm not
like dining with people,
I don't really like to take it slow.
I like to just eat it and
get on with what I'm doing.
- Yeah, if you're at
like a fancy restaurant,
I'd like to take my time.
- I'll be like, "Oh my God,
you have to try these
bananas, they're dashing."
- Slowly.
- Swerves the wine.
(all laughing)
- Oh my gosh, takes
one bite, sip wine. Ah.
(Joey laughing)
- I feel like that's part
of the experience. Right?
I think part of the
experience of enjoying food
with me is not just the food.
- Social aspect.
- It's the social aspect
and also the drink as well.
Getting your pair,
getting the food paired
with like the perfect drink,
actually like really
enhances the experience.
Right?
- I feel like,
just food tastes so much worse
when you're eating it alone.
Do you not think so?
- I actually agree with you.
(all laughing)
- You don't think so?
- It depends if it's
like a, b, c grade food.
- When I have good food,
I feel so sad when no one else is around
to appreciate the good food as well.
I'm like, "This is good man."
- So you take a picture and
you make a Google review.
- So whenever we got to
Meilyne's is good, right?
And then Meilyne like, "No."
But I'm loving it.
I'm like, "This is great."
- Sometimes I'm just like,
"I'm not gonna ask Meilyne,
because I am really
enjoying the meal right now.
And I'm afraid that she's
just gonna dash my dreams.
- No!
- Yeah, we had.
- She's like that reviewer that you don't
wanna hear the opinion of.
- Absolutely. (laughs)
- You be like, "Just let me enjoy my soda
that's online meal Meilyne.
I don't care about your opinion."
- It's a 9/10, right?
(all laughing)
No it sucks. It fucking sucks.
- I don't care if people
dislike my favorite shows.
But when I get to like,
when we're at the old studio,
and we had like the
stone baked pizza right?
- Yeah.
- That was really good.
- We loved it.
And it was like was at 4.5 or something.
It was really hard.
- yeah, it was fantastic.
- On Google reviews and we took Meilyne
and Meilyne was like,
"No. I can't eat it."
- It's just 'cause I don't
like pizza to begin with.
- What!
(Meilyne laughing)
What do you mean?
You're from like America?
- Wait, wait.
- Contender for the
shittiest take of the year.
- That's pretty bad. That's pretty bad.
Why?
- Wait, wait.
- There's no type of pizza you like?
- There is a specific pizza,
- One?
- That's made in San Francisco.
- Oh my God!
- Oh for fuck!
(Meilyne laughing)
- Oh my!
- Ah yes! Ah ye!
- And the entire world groans.
(Meilyne laughing)
- The home of pizza, San Francisco.
- But even though I could only
eat like one pizza a year.
I don't really like it.
- [Men] What?
- One pizza a year?
- Yeah.
- And it needs to be in
San Francisco apparently.
- I have never-
- Fuck, I just felt
all the Italians just fucking die.
- Yeah, Italian gasp.
- Mamma fucking mia,
what the fuck was that?
- There's better foods to
eat than pizza I think.
- I just thought every human
on earth enjoyed pizza.
- I just thought it was a mutual love.
- I just thought it was there.
I'm pretty sure it's like a test,
for like how to determine if
you're an alien or a human.
(all laughing)
"Cause if they don't probably love pizza,
then they're probably an alien right?
Because no human doesn't love pizza.
- What don't you like about about pizza?
Do you like cheese?
- I think it depends.
It's all about timing for
pizza when they get it out,
and how long were there cooking it.
It's crispy soggy,
and like so many places get it wrong.
(all laughing)
- How would you rate Domino's?
- I wouldn't rate it.
- It's like not even worth eating?
- Okay. There's some times,
there's some moments where
you're watching a movie
or something during a long break,
and you want to eat something greasy,
then pizza, the Domino's.
I'll eat Domino's.
- Right, right.
- But it's not like fricking amazing.
It's not like amazing.
- Okay. What is like
the best fast food then
in your opinion?
- If you say In and Out I swear to God.
- I like In and Out though.
I really like Inn and Out.
- But knowing how much
she loves San Francisco.
- I actually really like McDonald's.
- Yeah, me too. Me too.
- But American McDonald's
or Japanese McDonald's?
- Japanese McDonald's.
- It's all the same.
- No, it's not.
American McDonald's makes me sick.
- Have you had American hamburgers?
- No.
- American McDonald's makes Meilyne sick.
- McDonald's hamburgers are out of time.
- I just get the nugs.
Nugs are like universally
just the same everywhere.
- When they're freshly fried,
oh my god.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Nugs are great. The fries are great.
I think McDonald's fries are the best,
out of like the major chains.
- But if they're like soggy.
- Actually they're good
when they're soggy and cold
and they've kind of been
like sweating a bit.
- What is this? What is this?
Come on, you're joking.
(Meilyne laughing)
What is this?
- Google food reviewer.
(Connor laughs)
- This is the local expert when
you go on Google apparently.
- How to lose your credibility
in like five minutes.
- But also, the Google review thing,
it doesn't really mean much.
It just means I contribute a lot.
- How did that start?
I'm so curious about how you just-
- 'Cause you're literally the only person
I know who does this.
- I think it was an obsession 'cause like,
there would be new restaurants that pop up
and then I'd be the first one,
out of everyone in the neighborhood to-
- That is true Tokyo like
switches out restaurants
like crazy.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It is crazy how fast
restaurants pop up and go.
- Yeah.
- And it was really
cool whenever I log into
my Google maps account and be like,
"wow! This got 1.2 million
views on your photo."
I'm like, "Wow!"
Yeah.
(men groaning)
- How it feels to be a YouTuber.
(all laughing)
- No, no. Nobody comments.
They just look at it which I like,
like "Oh yay, they saw it."
- It's just a YouTube video
with the comments turned off.
- I went to a KFC one time
and uploaded a picture
of my friend eating a KFC.
And for some reason Google
made it the front picture.
(all laughing)
- I'm sorry to hear that.
- It was like you click on this KFC.
It's a pretty popular KFC.
And it was just him,
sitting there eating a KFC,
not a flattering photo.
- Why did you upload that?
- Because I wanted to see how it works.
- That's hilarious.
- I wanted to see how it worked.
And I found out afterwards,
you can't take down Google photos.
- No, you can't.
- And he was furious at me.
He was like, "Why did you put it up?"
- You can take down Google photos.
- Really?
- Yeah, I can.
- It wouldn't let me take it down.
- Maybe it's the privilege only.
(all laughing)
- You gotta be a google reviewer.
- Are you in the top 5%?
- Every week I go on
Google maps and it's like,
"Your picture is popular."
And I'm like, "What
the fuck it's my name?"
(all laughing)
But yeah, sorry to say.
So you start reviewing things?
- Yeah, yeah.
- When did you get addicted?
Was it like immediately or like?
- Like after two months, I
started eating at more places.
- So do you like go out on
purpose to look for new places
or do you kind of just like
wait till a new place pops up?
- Well, I get tired of
eating the same food a lot.
- Yeah.
- So when my husband asks
me, "Where do you wanna eat?"
I'll be like, "Can we go somewhere new?"
I just want like that
stimulation, that excitement.
- I hate it 'cause I never
used to be like that.
And then I moved to Japan
and then I'm just like,
"I wanna eat something
different every day."
- There's so many.
Japan has the most, for example,
Michelin restaurants in the world.
And you don't even have to eat
at a Michelin starred restaurant,
everything's extremely good.
- If you're a peasant.
- Do you rate the
Michelin star restaurants?
'Cause I know you've been to a few.
- I do. I do.
- You do? Okay.
- Yeah.
But it's also kind of
weird if you go there often
and then the chef knows you rated them.
So-
(Garnt laughing)
- They probably think you're like one
of the reviewers at this point.
- There's one restaurant
that I really liked.
- Yeah.
- And then I just don't
review it 'cause I don't want
them to know my thoughts. (laughs)
- What makes a good and a bad reviewer?
- A bad reviewer is just
like, "Oh, this place sucked
or it is too expensive."
- "Cause I normally only
give out five stars,
and I don't review
restaurants I don't like.
- Yeah, that's the problem.
I think a lot of people only
review restaurants they hate,
or some restaurants they really like.
- Yeah.
- They can't be bothered to
formulate a middle ground.
- Yeah, when I look at a place,
and then I see maybe
there's only three ratings.
And then I look at the three reviewers,
and this person only has two reviews.
This person has 40, I
look at their profile.
- So you don't look at just reviews.
You stalk the account of the reviewer.
You're like a jury analyzer you question
the credibility of the jurors.
- Yeah, because for example,
if these two reviewers
have a streak or record
of just giving two stars,
why would I trust the review?
- I just don't think I
have the effort to like
click on someone's review.
- It's 'cause you don't care
you just Uber eats everything.
- You don't even check the
restaurant before you try it.
- The people who normally
sound like the biggest dicks,
other like the local experts.
- Yeah, yeah.
- They're always have like
the most snobbish reviews,
and every time I read them I'm like,
"What the fuck happened?"
Like he made it seem like-
- How often do you read Google reviews?
- If I ever go to a new
place, I always look at them.
- I just look at the stars and I'm like,
"Yeah, that looks good enough."
- Is that Meilyne's influence?
- No, I just always did that.
- Oh, okay.
- 'Cause sometimes people
maybe like comment,
like the best dish,
or something they recommend.
- Oh yeah, pictures of,
'cause you don't know
what to order either.
- Sometimes I don't really know.
And occasionally I can't read
it 'cause it's all in Kanji.
And then I'm like, I point
at the picture I'm like,
"Give me this one."
- Yeah.
- "What this guy had."
- 'Cause it's like a menu.
- What this guy had.
You don't do that?
- No. Why not?
- Why am I the weirdo?
- Aren't there menus here
that have no pictures
and you can't read it?
- Yeah, in Kanji. Yeah, yeah.
- So you just go through the pictures.
- Sometimes you just got
to put your fate in God,
and just order food. I don't know.
- Just throw the dice.
- Just throw out the dice.
- What you do in that
situation is 'Ososume,'
ask for the recommendation.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Whatever he says you're like,
"Yes, I hope this is good."
- I just get whatever sounds nice.
I don't know, like sometimes.
- I just (speaks Japanese) that shit.
- Well Joey can read.
I can't, I'm dumb.
- Yeah, yeah.
- There's some like handwritten menus,
and I'm just like, "What?
- Oh yeah, those are so hard
to even remotely figure
out what's being said.
- Oh, if that's the case
then I asked the waitress.
I'm like, "What does that say?"
- I actually have the way-
- If you can't read it
then use the comic sounds.
- Sometimes I've seen
some handwritten ones
especially like really fancy
like Japanese restaurants,
where they're like,
love to use that like
traditional calligraphy style
and I'm like-
- Yeah.
- This just looks like squiggles to me.
- Like the one's with the
(speaks Japanese) menu.
- That is the one that changes everyday.
- The daily special.
- Like the daily special.
- I mean like daily specials I always ask,
but like I've seen menus
that is literally illegible,
where it's just so messy
and they always use like,
fancy terminology that
just doesn't work outside
of that context.
- French, Italian?
- My favorite moment of eating in Japan
is when you get to Riokan.
It's like 20 courses,
and they just come over to
you and explain every dish.
And I just look at the thing
for two minutes straight just nodding.
- See, I'm actually interested
in those kinds of menus though.
- I don't know what they're saying to me.
I'm just like, "What the
fuck are you saying?"
- Yeah.
- I'm like nodding, nodding, all right.
This is getting is a little excessive.
- In your head it's like, "This is food.
This is also food. This
is a food." (laughs)
- I think you eat it or
take like half a bite,
and then tell them, "What
is this that I just ate?"
And then they, that's better.
Like if they have time to explain.
- But like usually what
they do is they bring
all the food out right.
And then they explain it
and then they just fuck off.
So you don't even have enough
time unless you're eating it
as they're explaining it, right?
- And then you're just
like, "Come back please,
I need to know."
- come over here,
I want to try.
- I am formulating a review. (laughs)
- I took a picture and I have
to leaves notes next to it.
- I'm a local expert I'll
have you know. (laughs)
- Are you the local expert?
Do you get that badge as well?
- I think, I'm not sure.
- Like I'm just so curious,
how often do you have to eat somewhere new
to be in the top 5%.
- I have no idea.
I haven't been top 5%
since like 2017 or 2018.
- That's worrying because
you used to do quite
a lot of reviews.
- I think there's more now
- How many reviews does it
take to be in the top?
- I have no idea.
- It's becoming
more mainstream.
- Maybe.
- There's a Japanese guy
as well who's trying to review
every single Starbucks in Japan.
- Oh yeah. I know that guy.
- And it's like ridiculous.
- Do they taste all the same?
- That's what I wonder.
What can the difference be?
- Yeah, that's like going to
every McDonald's in Japan.
- He has to probably order the
same thing from each place.
So otherwise it's not a
good comparison. Right?
- [Camera Man] But I think
they have the seasonal menus.
- Yeah, now they have
Starbucks Japan just released
a thing where every single prefecture,
has its own frappe.
- Yeah.
- Oh does it?
- That's such a Japanese idea.
- It's actually really cool.
- It's kind of genius.
- They all look
super unique as well.
Like none of the flavors look the same.
- I went to Kyoto the
other day and I had like
the Kyoto frappuccino.
- Yeah.
- And it was like matched with
like caramel and some shit
and I'm like, "You're fucking up."
If I can only have this
here, I'll have it.
- The Tokyo one sucks.
- What's the Tokyo one?
- It's like coffee jelly and some shit.
- That is a very Tokyo
thing, the coffee jelly.
- Do you like jelly?
- Yeah.
- I think jelly is the worst dessert.
It is by far the worst.
- [All] No!
- Have you had Mikan jelly?
- I don't give a shit.
- Mikan jelly's bomb, that shit's bomb.
- Why's the jelly?
- Jelly is literally
the dessert of peasants.
- What are you talking about?
What are you actually talking about?
- Jelly is incorporated on all kinds
of high-end meals.
- It is literally
the cheapest dessert.
That's the cheapest one.
It's the cheapest one.
- How?
- Someone needs to take
this privilege away.
- Cheap can be delicious
though it doesn't have to be expensive
to be delicious.
- It tastes
like mattress filler I don't wanna eat it.
- Yeah because you don't
just want jelly by itself.
Right? Sometimes you want jelly by itself,
but if it's like
incorporated in the dessert.
- You don't like coffee jelly
with a bit of ice cream?
- No, I can't stand it. It's awful.
- Ah, I love coffee jelly.
- What don't you like about jelly?
- It tastes like nothing half the time.
And when it does taste like something,
it's like you could've made,
you could have made something else.
(all laughing)
You could have made
literally anything else
with this flavor profile,
and it would have been 10 times better,
'cause it didn't feel like
a floppy mess in my mouth.
- I'm gonna have you try Milkman jelly.
- It's just a very light flavor,
it's not too strong all the time.
It's just very light.
- Sometimes I don't want a dessert
that punches me in the face.
- It's like slippery and-
- It's just lighter
than like an ice cream.
- Is it more so the
texture you don't like?
- The texture is a massive part of it.
But I also find that-
- So you don't like gelatinous?
- No. And I find that the
flavors can be replicated
in any other dessert that is just better.
- Like what?
- Like ice cream, ice cream is better.
- (laughing) Ice creams?
- You mean an ice cream?
- Ice cream and jelly
don't taste anything alike.
What are you talking about?
- With coffee jelly you could
have done ice cream coffee.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah usually you get
like a vanilla ice cream
with coffee jelly.
Like that shit's great.
- Just put like an espresso on it.
(Joey laughing)
I'd just rather that,
don't do this jelly shit.
Fuck that jelly shit.
- I'm sorry ice cream and
jelly tastes nothing alike.
Even if they have the same flavor profile.
- Yeah.
- It's like two totally different things.
- It's the texture I don't know.
I find that it's like,
I never-
- I just don't think
you're a fan of gelatinous things.
- No and it's also like
when they do it I'm like,
"Really couldn't afford
gelato or ice cream really?"
I feel like that's what's going on.
(Garnt laughing)
Peasants.
I'm like, "Oh, okay."
- Conner's at a Michelin Star restaurant,
they're serving him with jelly.
- Have you been to a
Michelin Star restaurant
before?
- Yeah.
- Oh, you have.
- And if they gave me jelly I'd be like,
"Wow! I saw where you
skimmed on the budget."
I can make 20 liters of
jelly in like 10 minutes,
with like 10 bucks.
I don't want this shit.
Do you know how hard it would be to fill
a bath tub of ice cream?
- That shit's going to actually
taste like nothing though.
Like the jelly that comes out
of like higher end restaurants
actually has a lot of
flavor in my opinion.
- Yeah, if it's like fruit they'll extract
the juices from the fresh fruit.
- Oh God I hate fruit jelly so much.
- Fruit jelly is the best.
- Why? Fruit jelly is the best.
- Fruit jelly is literally the best.
- Why would you ruin fruit by
making it into a jelly format?
It's literally the worst.
- No, there's some fruits that are better.
- Yeah, like Milkan.
- Yeah, Milkan.
- I would argue that
fruits make better jellies
than they do ice cream.
- Yeah.
- I agree.
- No.
- Actually yes.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yes.
- You can try it's full potential.
The texture of how it's changed
by being cooked in the syrup.
- Look, look, look fruit
jelly is refreshing as fuck.
Fruit ice cream is not refreshing.
A lot of the time.
- Unless it's sorbet.
- Banana ice cream does not count.
- Banana, strawberry, cherry.
- Banana ice cream
does not taste like banana.
- I will take strawberry jelly
over strawberry ice cream any day.
- Oh! What?
- I've never had a good
strawberry jelly though.
- Well strawberry jelly's
normally like the cheap,
the cheap jelly.
- The "jello type."
- The jello type.
It's only The Cheap Jelly But Like,
so is strawberry ice cream.
Strawberry ice cream is normally
the cheap ice cream as well.
- I don't like strawberry ice cream.
- Oh my God! Oh my God Joey! (laughs)
This is why we're brothers.
- Well listen, I don't like it either,
but I would take it over jelly.
(men laughing)
- Fuck off.
- Strawberry ice cream I think is just
like the worst ice cream flavor.
- It always tastes like fake strawberries.
- Yeah.
- Banana though.
- Banana's good but it's not,
that's not the same flavor
as an actual banana.
- But why does banana blend
itself so well to everything?
Like everything banana
flavor, tastes amazing.
- Yeah, I agree with that.
- And like everything orange
takes so artificial and shit.
- No.
- Yes.
- Like orange ice lollies
are like orange ice without lollies.
(all laughing)
- Why did you point at me?
Why the fuck did you point at me?
(all laughing)
I didn't say anything.
Did you guys catch that slang,
- [Meilyne] Why did you?
- Let's just talk about the lollies.
- Did you catch that?
Or it's because we say it in Australia.
Okay yeah.
- Yeah, we say it in the UK too though.
- Oh you didn't say that.
- I don't know why you
pointed at me though.
That was just slang language.
(all laughing)
- It just the way it
just came out of nowhere,
like "Oh, lollies".
(all laughing)
- I can't believe you man.
- We call them ice lollies as well.
- Oh, the UK?
- The lollipops, right.
Americans call them lollipops too right?
- Yeah, lollipops.
- Yeah.
- Don't change the subject.
- So yeah, orange tastes like shit.
- No, you're wrong.
- Tastes like shit?
- You're wrong.
I think the orange desserts tastes better
than banana desserts.
- Oh, no. Oh come on.
- Do you like mousse by the way.
- Yeah, I like mousse.
- Mousse?
- Sometimes.
(Joey laughing)
(all laughing)
- Do you just hate desserts Connor?
- I love ice cream.
(all laughing)
- We found the reason
jellies and gentlemen,
we found the reason.
- Categorically right?
I have not had a single dessert, right?
That I'm like ice cream would
just be better than this.
Not a single dessert made me
think ice cream is better.
- I can find you a dessert.
- Or like apple pie. Apple pie is great.
- It's okay, but I can
find you something better.
- What's the thing that you said sorry?
- You only like apple pie
because it works well
with ice cream. (laughs)
(all laughing)
Anything that works well with ice cream.
- Do you like chocolate cake?
- I love chocolate cake.
- What kind of chocolate cake?
The Japanese chocolate cake?
- Oh I don't think I've ever
had Japanese chocolate cake.
- Or like a volcano chocolate cake.
- American chocolate cake.
- Sometimes icing is
just too heavy, you know?
Sometimes it's like cement like and-
- It gets lighter when you microwave it.
- (air whooshing) That just sounds.
- That's the tidbit for the day.
- No, it's so good.
- Why would you want mousse?
'Cause to me mousse is
just an inferior ice cream.
- Mousse does taste bad
most of the time though.
- Sometimes you just don't
want something as heavy,
as ice, just have cream,
which is a cream.
- Just have less ice cream.
- No, even a spoon of the
cream fills your mouth
with the cream though.
- If Americans saw the
Haagen-Dazs size in Japan,
then they'd cry.
I cried when I first saw it.
Have you seen how tiny?
- No, to me that's the perfect size.
- Yeah.
- I can't have any more
Haagen-Dazs than that.
- But I won't lie, I
do wish I had the tub.
Just so if I really did have a bad day,
I could chow down the 2 liter tub.
- Like dessert's the one
meal where I'm really picky
because it depends on what
I've eaten directly beforehand.
That dictates what dessert I order. Right?
You can't just order the
same dessert every time.
- I don't even eat dessert.
- I agree that ice cream I
think is the best dessert.
It's either ice cream or cake. Right?
If I have an empty stomach I'd always go
for ice cream or cake.
But like, sometimes you
just don't feel like that
after a really heavy meal.
Sometimes chocolates
just seems way too heavy.
And you just want something light or-
- Yeah.
- Always tiramisu or
ice cream in some form.
(Garnt laughing)
Tiramisu, I could have like anything
and I can eat half a tiramisu after.
- To be fair, tiramisu
is my favorite cake,
but I can't have it after every meal.
- I can have it after every meal.
- It's a very heavy cake.
- It's a heavy cake.
- It feels like it's heavy.
- It doesn't feel heavy at all.
- The cream.
- To me the biggest fucking
lie I hear people say is like,
"Oh, you have a second
stomach for dessert."
I'm like, "Bullshit."
- That shit's a lie.
- Bullshit.
You just didn't eat enough
main course, that's it.
- No, it's actually true.
- Fuck you off.
- You could check your mind to it.
- The way your taste buds
work is that they get sick
of one flavor so when you
introduce a new flavor,
it makes more room for it.
- No, just not with me.
- That's how you conquer buffets.
You switch back and forth.
- Conquer buffets.
(Garnt laughing)
- I watched a very informal
Vox video about this,
and apparently yeah you tend to-
- Oh my god, I want to
see Meilyne at a buffet.
- I can't eat as much there is.
- Oh hi, its me Joey,
here to do the sponsors for this episode.
And you'll be happy to
know that this episode
of "Trash Taste" is sponsored
by "Genshin Impact."
"Genshin Impact" is an
open world action RPG game
available on PC, Android,
iOS and PlayStation 4 and 5.
Step into a vast magical world now
and start your adventure
on the continent of Teat,
where seven kinds of
elemental power surge.
You guys should know
"Genshin Impact" by now.
It's taken the internet
by storm at this point,
but in case you've been living
under a rock and didn't know,
"Genshin Impact" has some
exciting updates for you all.
A new update for version 2.1
is the Floating World
under the Moonlight update.
After joining the resistance troops,
travelers are now fighting
against the Shogunate.
And all mysteries will
unfold in the final chapter
of Inazima Archon Quest,
omnipresence over mortals.
We have the brand new character
Raiden Shogun available
to pull between 1st of September
to the 21st of September,
the Undisputed Supreme ruler of Inazima.
Her Excellency, the
almighty Narukami Ogosho,
promised the people of
Inazuma an unchanging eternity
to last throughout the ages.
But if you have a bad
history of pulling 5 stars
then don't worry,
there's also a brand
new four star available
for you as well.
The four star electro
character Kujou Sara is here,
leader of the tengu commission's force,
bold, decisive, and skilled in battle.
As the adopted daughter of the Kujo clan,
she conducts herself with an
official demeanor at all times.
And there's another beautiful five-star,
awaiting for your hands to get ahold of.
I'm of course, talking
about Sangonomiya Kokomi,
the new five-star hydro character.
The divine priestess is Supreme leader
of the Watatsumi Island.
But if characters aren't
your thing then don't worry.
There's lots more juicy
information for you all.
Because two of the new Inazuma
Islands will open to play
as the Watatsumi Island
and the Seirai island.
Watatsumi island is very different
from other islands in Inazuma.
The Sangonomiya shrine is located
at the center of this island surrounded
by a canopy of mountains and waterfalls.
Meanwhile, Seirai Island is
where some disasters seem
to have occurred and is surrounded
by perpetual thunderstorms.
Plus there are a number
of exclusive events
available as well.
Like the Moon Chase Festival
from the 17th of September
to the 12th of October.
And of course the first
anniversary celebration
starting off with the
passage of clouds event,
which is a login bonus event
that let's players accumulate
daily log-ins from the 20th of September,
to claim up to 10 intertwine fate
along with various other rewards.
So even if you're a new player
or an experienced player,
"Genshin Impact" has a
lot to offer to you guys.
So make sure to go down,
to the link in the description below,
to check out the game for yourself.
And thank you to "Genshin Impact"
for sponsoring this episode.
Back to the show.
- Here's a buffet for peasants mainly.
(Garnt laughing)
- Depends where you go.
- Dessert swap strat.
- Where can we get a good buffet?
- Las Vegas has a lot of good buffets.
- I've heard this actually.
- You'll pay like 100 almost $300.
- But isn't it mainly
buffets in Las Vegas?
- It's all buffets.
- Really?
- Yeah. 'Cause you know
Hulki's from Vegas, right?
So like literally every
third day is a buffet.
And after a while I'm just like,
"Bruh, can we have like something else.
Just like a single meal."
- Yeah.
I get it though 'cause
you're just gonna sit there
and gamble all night.
So it doesn't matter if you
like just stuff yourself.
- Yeah.
Well, if you do feel like walking around
on the strip all day.
- Yeah.
- And you have enough room,
then yeah of course a Buffet's fantastic.
But if I'm like fucking lazily
sitting around in the house,
and then sometimes Hulki's mom's like,
"Let's go to a buffet."
I'm like, "No, please no. I can't."
- But they have no time limit,
you could be there all day kind of.
- Actually some of them
look amazing as well.
I think I saw some YouTube videos of them
and it's like Michelin
star chefs or something.
- Yeah.
- We've been to all of
them and some of them
are fucking amazing.
- Did you go on the buffet bus tour?
You get a pass and it takes
you around to all the buffets.
- No, I haven't. I know a
friend who went on that.
- Why would you wanna
have a pass that takes you
on the same day?
- I've always wanted to go.
- Dude when I start eating.
- That's like a buffet of a buffet.
(all laughing)
- No I want to.
- That's just horrible.
When I start eating,
I don't want to stop until I'm done.
- Yeah.
- And then when I'm done, I stop.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
because the worst thing is
when you are right timed
for my meal.
- Yeah.
- And the worst thing is if you-
- Get on the bus, we're going.
- If you start a meal and
you're not totally full,
but then you stop because you stop anyway
'cause you've gotta leave or
you've gotta do something else
and then you kind of become full
but not the satisfying full.
- Yeah.
- You're just like the
bloated full. Right?
- Yeah.
And that sounds like an awful experience.
- If you had to do that on
the same day and the buffet.
- It's fun for like
college student aged people
I think when you have a lot of friends.
- I'm so sorry there was a single causes.
- Why don't you just go to one buffet then
instead of going to multiple.
- I wouldn't go to a buffet now though
but I did used to really like buffets.
- I still do love buffets.
It's just that there's a
time and a place for it.
I can't have it every day.
- Yeah, I can't have it every way.
- Wait, how do you rate buffets then
because there's so many
different types of those?
- I can't rate buffets.
I didn't do Google reviews back
when I was eating at buffets.
- Have you heard we
have our Japan buffets?
Have you had the buffets here?
- Yeah, I took you guys,
I think that only Connor and Garnt.
- Did we really have buffet?
- Yeah, Nabezo. It's a hot pot buffet.
- Oh that doesn't count.
- That is a buffet.
- To Me it's not a buffet.
If you have to ask the guy to come over,
and then you order more stuff.
- Yeah, but then you go over
to the vegetable section,
you get your own vegetables.
- That's not a buffet.
- That is a buffet.
- That's a salad bar.
- Yeah.
- Oh!
- That's a fucking salad-
- That's a self serve salad bar.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I'd say 'cause buffet
to me is truly like everything
is you can go up and get it.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- So I feel like when there's a block
and you have to call
someone over and be like,
"Can I have more meat?"
- That's how you get the fresh one.
- But you can also like go up
to like the chef at the buffet
and be like, "Can you
get me the fresher one?"
- Depending at the buffet,
I know the Las Vegas ones had that.
- Yeah, Vegas you can do that.
- There's some really weird
buffets in Japan though.
I went to one-
near the-
- At the Switch Buffet?
- A company has buffet-
- It's like an American
chain or something.
- American chain, here?
- It's apparently supposed to
be an American dining chain.
- Sizzler?
- Sizzler? Was the one?
- Sizzler in Japan has like
the "famous salad buffet bar."
- Yeah, and it was the most-
- There's sizzlers in Japan?
- Yeah there's Sizzlers in-
- Oh my God!
- I think I went to one in Tokyo stadium
or Edabashi stadium.
The one near Edabashi. Right?
It's like a stage, the
massive stadium the park.
- Tokyo Dome?
- Tokyo Dome. That's it.
- Yeah.
- There was one in there.
- Was it Sizzler?
- Or some form of chain.
- A Bubba Gumps?
- I don't know, it wasn't Bubba Gumps.
I went to it and I was like,
"All right, what's
gonna be on the buffet?"
It was the weirdest selection
of stuff you can imagine.
- Right.
- The dessert was like
first in the buffet as well.
So it was like ice cream,
(all laughing)
and like French toast but
this was like 5:00 PM.
- What do you mean first in the buffet?
- When you get your tray and stuff,
the dessert was there first.
- Oh weird.
- And then I was like, "Okay."
And the next tray is like,
self service taco station,
but there was no sauce or guac.
So it was just like beef.
- This is beef wrapped up on-
- On the tortilla.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Tortilla pack.
- Both of those.
- (laughing) Mexicans crying.
- It was just beef and the tortilla.
- Yeah. There you go. (laughs)
- I was like, "Okay.
Yeah. This makes sense."
Next up it's like,
pasta, Italian pasta.
And it was like, "I don't
know what this pasta was."
It didn't taste like anything.
It tastes like a weird Arabiatta,
it was really strange.
And then in the middle there
was like a bunch of salad,
but the salad was strange as well.
There was like barely any lettuce.
There was like chopped oranges,
like a bunch of croutons and stuff.
I was like, "What is this?"
- Is this in the hotel?
- Yeah. Next to it.
- At the hotel buffet?
- No, it wasn't a part of the hotel.
- 'Cause Tokyo Dome
Hotel also has buffets.
- It was so confusing and
it was just the weirdest.
I've never seen a buffet like it.
And half the stuff was terrible,
and they didn't have a
coffee machine or anything,
it was water.
It was just water.
- Peasants.
- Instant soft.
(Garnt laughing)
- It was just water.
And if you wanted the soft
drink, you had to order it.
- That's actually normal in
a lot of buffet practice,
in England as well,
because that's how they make the money.
Because you have to pay for the drinks.
- We pay for the drinks in the UK?
- Some buffet places,
a lot of buffet places,
the drinks aren't included.
- I thought it was just
for alcoholic drinks.
- Oh no. They charge for
like normal drinks as well.
- And that's like the secret
of how they make the money.
Because you have to order
the drink separately,
but the food is like all you can eat.
Right?
- Right, right.
- So, that's more standard.
- How much are buffets in the UK?
- Oh, it depends.
- If potato is like standard,
you can go to pretty high
end and get like 20 pounds.
- Really? In the south it's like 20 to 30.
- Oh shit! Really up
in the North it's not.
It's like a 10.
- Oh my God! I was like up north.
Oh my God! That's so cheap.
- Buffets around where I
was I think they were like,
never more than 20 and
20 was like premium.
- Oh my God!
- Well like farm produce
in your area?
- You can't eat out in the south,
like less than 15 quid,
like 15 quid's like the cheap,
cheap, cheap restaurants.
- You could go to any restaurant
and get a main for like 10 pounds.
Like in a fresh main that's prepared well.
So why would you go to a buffet,
and stuff yourself full of chips and rice,
and pay 15 quid.
(Joey laughs)
- Fair enough.
- Buffets are just fun
for family, I think.
- Are they? Are they?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, 'cause you can challenge people.
- You should get your kid
to shop and run away. Right?
- Challenge people? What
do you challenge people?
- Who can conquer it first?
(all laughing)
- Isn't it funny to do that as a teenager?
- You only eat one place.
- When I was a teenager I
did think it was really cool.
And there was an all you
can eat buffet one time,
and the pizza.
- Did you wear buffet pants?
- What?
- Like stretchy pants.
- There's an all you can
eat buffet pizza chain
here in Japan as well.
Yeah, called Shakey's.
- Oh, I've heard of this.
- That's American.
- In Bubby, they have that.
- Can we go back to the buffet pants?
What the fuck is the buffet pants?
- I didn't even hear that.
(all laughing)
- She said buffet?
- She was like,
"Did you wear buffet pants?
- They're just sweats,
so you can put the elastic
band over your stomach
when you're done eating.
- That sounds like the
most American invention
I've ever heard of.
- Everyone did it in my circle.
- In San Francisco?
- In my circle.
We were like, "Let's go to the buffet."
And then we change her pants.
- I remember we went to a-
- (laughing) Oh what? What?
- This sounds like a parody.
- No, it's real. It's real.
- Are you serious?
- Well in my friend group.
- Did other friend groups do this as well?
- I don't know.
- Was this like a just your
friend group type of thing.
- No, it was like more than 20 people.
- How much does a buffet
cost in San Francisco?
- $40?
- $40!
- This was like eight years ago though.
- Well, it's only gotten more now?
- $90 now?
- Eight years ago?
- Yeah, that's how much Vegas buffets are.
They're like 40, $50.
- Holy fuck!
- Are they worth it?
- They don't taste good.
- Don't eat those ones.
- The high-end ones though
where you pay a little extra
like 80, $90 is like worth it.
- $80, $90 what the fuck?
- So do you get like
sirloin steak on demand?
- Yeah, actually.
- It's about the crab.
- You actually get like top
tier food at those buffets.
- All right okay.
- But the $40, $50 ones in my opinion,
maybe half the time not worth it.
- Two grand and then spend $90 on steak.
That's terrible.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, that sounds alien to
me because like in the UK,
I don't think that kind of buffet exists.
Buffets exist as like a cheap alternative,
to eating a lot of food
if you just wanna order
a lot of food.
You either eat a shit ton of food.
It didn't really care about the quality.
- But there are a lot
of Indian Curry buffets
because in SF certain areas.
- Pretty much every buffet in
the UK has Indian Curry in it.
- Oh really?
- I'm gonna be honest there,
they're pretty bad though.
They're really fucking bad.
- I would argue that pretty like 90,
actually I don't think I've ever been
to a good buffet place in the UK.
In terms of like, this is good food.
You go there, to eat a shit ton of food,
and you trick your brain,
into thinking it tastes good
because you're eating so much food.
But in reality it just tastes like shit.
- I think that's most buffets.
(all laughing)
- I'll just hate like
the whole plate situation
with buffets.
Because when you get a dish right,
that you've hand selected,
it's normally perfectly
fit for that plate.
When you start going around the buffet
and you start putting things on,
I don't want some of the foods touching.
- Yeah.
- And I hate that because I'm like,
I don't want the saucy
dish to touch the thing
that's supposed to be like dry.
- Yeah.
- So it's kind of a mess.
But if there is sauce, it's like,
all right, if this dish
has a lot of sauce,
how do I kind of like integrate
this with my other food
selection on my plate?
- I have honestly never
cared because I'm like,
at the end of the day, this is
all going to turn into shit.
So, it doesn't matter to me.
(speakers arguing indistinctly)
- You just get a new plate.
- You can't just say whatever
goes in your mouth is shit,
so why give a fuck.
- I actually don't.
- 'Cause like I'm the guy at the buffet.
- You should just eat
like cement. (laughs)
- I'm like the guy at the buffet,
who has like fucking three
different plates. Right?
Because somethings you can't mix.
- I take that right.
I go and get another plate to make sure
that the dishes are right.
- You don't get the food, put it down,
eat it and then go again?
- No, no.
- No, because that's too much effort.
- What if you change your mind though
after you eat the first food?
- Just throw it away.
- It's all gonna get thrown out anyway.
- What if you take your
standard instead of taking
too much of something starchy,
and I've been like,
"Shit I can't eat this."
This is prime real estate in my stomach.
I can't have another bread roll.
So I just leave it.
- 'Cause in Vegas apparently.
- I never get bread, when I'm in a buffet.
You mad man.
- I'm kidding-
- Cause in Vegas apparently it's a law now
that all the buffet places
at the end of every day,
they have to throw out like everything,
because there was this
lawsuit that dead ass,
I read about this.
There was this lawsuit that
happened a couple of years ago,
where they kept some of the food,
and like stored it in like the behind,
like the stare and some
homeless guy came up,
ate it, got food poisoning,
sued the buffet place and won.
- What?
- Well hopefully he got a nice home.
- Yeah.
- What?
- what?
- And so now in Vegas,
I don't know about the
whole state of Nevada,
but in Vegas every buffet place,
legally has to throw out
every single food that's left
on that day and make
it fresh the next day.
So, I can't imagine how much
food that's thrown away.
- I mean that's good for customers though
but unfortunately terrible for-
- It's also a waste of
a shit load of food.
- You'd wish they'd just gave it away
but it's logistically it's quite hard
to just give away a lot of food.
- Like donate it to the shelters?
- [Men] Yeah.
- I think some coffee chains in the UK,
especially London, I
think like Pret does it,
where like at the end of the day,
someone will come in and
get all the sandwiches
that didn't sell and then that night go
and take them to homeless people.
- Yeah.
- oh yeah.
So that makes more sense.
- So they're still lucky
to eat.
That's good.
- I am curious, as like
the resident American here.
- Oh, yeah.
- Well I'm the only American.
- Pretty much the only American -
- You're the only American in the office?
- Yeah right, apart from Sydney.
- Yeah.
- But Sydney doesn't count.
- What?
(Garnt laughs)
- I mean she likes Ugly Birds 10 times
but none of her opinions mean anything.
I'm like how'd you feel
when we actually like rant about America
and you're just off-camera listening?
- I'm just like, that's true.
(all laughing)
- Confirmation.
- Almost the same thing.
- Yeah, you have been wrong,
but I'm just saying, "Ah whatever."
It means everything.
- Yeah, we rank on about our
own countries just as much.
- Yeah and then also Americans will rag
on your countries and whatnot.
- Yeah, of course.
- It's interesting though 'cause
most of my foreign friends
are usually American,
and it's interesting hearing,
non-Americans talk about
Americans that I know.
- Has there ever been a time though
where you were just like,
"No, that's so wrong.
I don't wanna tell them."
- There are a few times but I just forgot.
I mean the one that
sticks out is the butter
or the lard thing.
Joey, you were saying
that there's someplace
that they put lard on
popcorn or something.
- Yeah.
- I've never heard of that. (laughs)
- Did we ever find out where
that was or was it a lie?
- I don't know.
- I have no idea
but I was like, "What?"
- It's not a lie because
I saw it with my own eyes.
(Garnt laughing)
So it's like, it's not a lie.
Maybe it was that cinema, I don't know,
but I saw it.
- In Vegas?
- Yeah, it's probably
not like a common thing.
- With melted butter is
definitely a common thing.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
- Did you speak to many non-Americans
who speak English before?
- Non-Americans who speak English.
- In Japan?
- Like Koreans?
- I guess so yeah.
- Is there a big difference
between Americans
and non-Americans?
- The way you guys talk,
some things you say and
then I end up saying it.
I'm like-
(Garnt laughing)
- Like what?
- I don't know.
- Like the time that
I almost convinced you
that the Australian
currency was the way it is.
- Yeah, I didn't believe you,
I was just being polite to your friends.
(all laughing)
- So at Smash, which is
the convention in Sydney.
The anime one.
- A few years ago.
- Yeah, so I got invited as a guest
and Meilyne came with me.
- Yeah.
- And,
my friend from uni was there.
I invited them,
and I don't know how we
got onto the conversation,
but my friend dead ass
almost convinced Meilyne
that the Australian currency
was called dollarydoos.
- And then before going I
actually had an Australian friend
here and she was like,
"Oh, Australians lie a lot.
So watch out."
(Joey laughing)
And then I think I told you.
I was like, "My friend said,
'Australians lie a lot.'"
- No, no, no, nonsense.
And then we told you about the drop bears.
- I knew about the drop bears.
- What is a drop bear?
- Drop bears are like there's
a specific type of bear
in Australia where they
drop from the tree.
They drop down and attack you.
When you're in Australia,
you should never fall asleep under a tree
because drop bear could
come down and attack you.
- Unfortunately that is a lie as much-
- No, no, no. It's absolutely real.
And Meilyne believed me for a while.
- I did not.
- Yeah, you did.
You were like, "Are they like
an actual species of bear?"
- Where did the drop bear thing come from?
- It's been around since like-
- Every Australian I
swear I've met abroad,
tells that story like on my first meeting.
I'm just like, "Is this
just something the country
has just agreed to tell the
entire rest of the world?"
- Well 100s of Australians have died
from drop bears every year.
- Prove that Australia really exists.
(Joey laughing)
Prove that it's not a lie.
- I haven't seen it yet.
- I haven't seen it.
I have never been to Australia.
Have you been to Australia?
- Yeah, she's been.
- Have I?
- Yeah.
- She went on a flight
and she landed somewhere,
that was called Australia.
But that doesn't mean it exists.
- There used to be a big gamer back
in the day, right Meilyne?
You used to play "MapleStory?"
- Yeah, (laughs)
so much.
(all laughing)
- I was wondering where
that transition was going.
- Wait, why did you
bring that up? (laughs)
- Did you not talk to
people on "MapleStory?"
- Oh yeah.
- People from other countries.
- Yeah, my guild mother
was from Australia?
- Did she lie a lot?
- I don't think so.
She told me about a lot of things.
- Like the drop bears?
- What's a guild mother?
- I don't know.
- It's the person who starts the guild.
- It's pretty fucking self-explanatory.
(all laughing)
- I've never heard of it referred
to as a Guild mother yet.
- It just happens that
online people in the games,
they date each other and you
can get married in "MapleStory"
and get crush rings or whatever.
- Did you crush rings? (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah.
- So did you not have like questions
about Australia for her?
- Not so much.
- Because I remember the first time
I met an American friend,
I asked them about so much shit.
About just like, is it true that like.
'Cause you know, in Australia-
'Cause you only hear so
much from media, right?
To the point where like,
a lot of it is like over-glorified
and sometimes just like a straight up lie.
So like the first time I
met my American friend,
through YouTube,
I just asked them like
a shit ton of questions.
Being like, "Is this true? Is this true?"
- I did ask my Brazilian
friend about Brazil though,
on "MapleStory."
- About what?
- Did they really have big butts?
- No, I asked them 'cause
there's this one case,
the rumor or something
that kids are very violent
when they get angry at
each other in games,
they like kill each other.
And one of the cases that
I was like checking out
was this 13 year old that
stole a PS4 or something
of his friend and the friend got angry,
went over to his house with the machete,
and just cut him in half.
And I was like, "Oh, is that true?"
And then my friend Tiago
was like, "Yeah, yeah.
That happens all the
time. So I'm not sure."
- Yeah, yeah. (laughs)
- He didn't say yeah, yeah.
He was like, "Yeah, that
happens a lot in ventrillo."
- Can people confirm that in the comments?
- The Brazilians?
- Brazilians.
Is it true?
- Can you confirm that?
- Brazilians, is it true?
- I don't know. I was like 13, 14.
- Does every Brazilian
kid just own a machete?
(all laughing)
- No, I don't know.
- They're readily
available before they learn
how to read and write,
they just get a machete.
- Does it come on Amazon or something?
- I don't know. I was 13.
And they told me that and I was like,
"Oh, Brazil is scary."
- I was always like the token British guy.
I went online to people,
they were just like, "Oh, it's a Brit."
- I've never met any
British people in the games.
- Really?
- None.
- Maybe they played on different servers.
- Maybe they did.
- May be.
- Yeah, like how much
growing up did you know
about the rest of the world?
'Cause like the stereotype
is that Americans,
know nothing about the rest of the world.
That's like the stereotype.
I'm not saying it's true, but like.
- I didn't know about
Europeans or Australians,
or South Americans so much.
- You were familiar the Japanese right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Oh yeah, that's true.
- I got to travel to a
lot of parts of Asia,
so I know about Asia.
- I don't know much about Asia.
I know the names of the countries
and some of the history.
- And now you're in Japan. (laughs)
- Yeah. Yeah.
- There you go.
- And now you're learning,
you're educating yourself. (laughs)
- About the culture.
- I knew about the history.
(all laughing)
- You knew the history,
we colonized this place.
(all laughing)
- When you're in another
country, you're like,
that's one that we used to have, right?
(all laughing)
- You just look at the list it's like,
"Is that part of my country?"
- It's really like we would name it like?
- Yeah.
(Connor laughing)
(all laughing)
- [Camera Man] They
appreciate the English.
- Often you'd hear about countries.
And it was always like,
it was like 50, 50.
I'm like, "Did we?"
I don't know.
- We got close. (laughs)
- Yeah, maybe we just stop right there.
English history's just really
cool when you learn about it.
Which is never taught in school in the UK
'cause they were like,
"That's that far away place
that you'll never go."
Because Europe and
Butlins is an hour away.
- But at least you guys got to learn
about like European history. Right?
- Oh, well fuck that though.
European history is such a fucking mess.
- Is it?
- Yes.
- Dude, better than Australian history.
We only have 250 years
and most of it is racism.
- Yeah but at least you can say like,
(all laughing)
- European history isn't any better.
- I don't think Europeans are
any better in terms of that.
- It's literally white
man come to person's land,
take land away, here we are today.
- And then dump the prisoners on them.
- Bunch of politics, blah, blah, blah.
And here we are.
- Europe spent like
fucking 900 years arguing
about who was the best white person.
- Yeah, but least you guys had like wars
and like colonies and
all that kind of stuff.
- Yeah, like cool shit.
- You guys had like the Romans
and like the Byzantines
and like all those.
Like that shit's cool.
- Yeah, that's cool.
- They make movies out of those.
- Yeah.
(Meilyne laughing)
- There's one movie about Australia
and it's called "Australia."
- Isn't it cool though-
- is it?
I've never seen them.
- Nicole Kidman.
Nicole Kidman and Hugh Jackman.
- That's cool though you can
learn all of your history
within like a reasonable amount of time.
- Yeah, but as a 14 year old learning
about like politics and shit.
I'm just like, "I don't care."
- I don't know most of European history.
I don't know history
was like that one class
that I just never paid attention to.
- I loved history.
- I hated history class.
- Do you know
about US history a lot?
- No.
The most world history I know
is from the fucking video
from Bill Wirtz.
(all laughing)
That's basically-
- What a sad way.
- After Bill Wirtz,
everyone is a fucking Japanese historian.
- It's like, "Hello, I am now historian."
(all laughing)
Hello, fellow historians.
- I know world history now.
To be fair, I learned a
lot from those videos.
- Yeah, I did learn a
lot from it 'cause I just
never paid attention in history class.
'Cause I dunno.
- Yeah, I love history man.
- But I wish I could learn like,
about like the Japanese
history or you know,
like actually about like
a history of a country
that is like I actually I'm interested.
- I think Japanese history
is interesting as fuck.
- Japanese history is super interesting.
- I think Chinese history
is interesting as fuck.
- Yeah. I wish I learned about that stuff,
like that 4,000 years of history
that you can look back on. Right?
- Yeah, 'cause that's fucking cool.
- That's like so much history
and it's just like one place as well.
Whereas with European it's just like,
"Is it the Romans this time
or like where is it Greece?"
- Well Europe had a war like
every fucking five years.
- I know right. (laughs)
- What percentage of like the
history classes that you took
or had to take in high
school or middle school,
where it was dedicated to European history
versus everything else?
- It was all European history.
- Oh, was it?
- Mine wasn't.
- But what other history did you learn?
- American.
- I did not learn anything
about American history.
- We learned American and Chinese history.
- How did they teach American history?
- It was mainly the civil rights period.
We covered 50 space,
yeah the generic.
- That's right.
- The highlights of the
modern American history
that they like to tell
because it sounds good.
It's like we beat racism.
(Joey laughing)
It's ended.
We beat the Russians,
(all laughing)
that kind of stuff.
- Yeah, I've never learned about all that.
- China was just like,
I don't know which one is the correct one.
There's multiple presentations of Mao.
Is Mao Zedong,
which pronunciation's
correct 'cause we got taught
a bunch of different ones.
- There's like 20 different
pronunciations of Mao.
- I don't know which one's correct.
- Every British person trying
to like pronounce Chinese words.
- Terrible. We learned about that.
- See, that's cool though
because we had in Australia.
At least in my school
we had ancient history,
which was like about like the Romans.
- We didn't do any ancient history.
- Egyptians, that kind of stuff.
- That's what we learned as well.
- And then we had modern history,
which was about World War 1, World War 2,
Vietnam war.
- We did so much on world war 2.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause British people love World War 2.
- They fucking love it.
- Of course they do.
- Literally they're like, "Look guys,
we beat the odds."
- Yeah.
- "We did it, we got 'em."
- Yeah, 'cause like I
only remember world war 1
and world war 2 being taught in my school.
I think we were taught a
bit of American history,
but it was just very glossed over.
I don't know why.
I don't know why it was glossed over.
- At least for me I don't know
if it was because we have GCSE,
which are like when you get to age 16,
you can pick three or four subjects.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- One of them was history I chose.
So that's why.
- Oh, you chose history.
- That's why I did.
We learned American history
and Chinese history.
- Oh, okay 'cause the most I did-
- The generic one was
just like world war 2.
- Yeah, I did the generic shit.
I've only done the
generic shit up to GCSE,
which I didn't even pick history.
- It was just always
like trench foot is bad.
- Do you have accelerated like
history classes here like AP?
- No, we don't do that in the UK.
The only one that has it is math.
We have advanced mathematics.
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's called further maths.
(speakers arguing indistinctly)
I know it 'cause I took it.
- That's the only subject
in the UK that had it.
(all laughing)
- Who would have thought the
two Asians on the podcast
took accelerated maths.
(all laughing)
- Accelerated maths?
- Yeah, we called it-
- Oh Gosh!
- Accelerated maths.
- Yeah, ours was called accelerated maths.
- Is that like trigonometry or something?
- No, trigonometry was the basic stuff.
- You had to like pass trigonometry
as to get to further maths.
- Accelerated maths was like,
like three dimensional graphs.
- Yeah, imaginary numbers.
- Imaginary numbers
and stuff like that.
- Okay.
- But I did notice like when I compared
what I learned at school to
what Sydney learnt at school
at the same time especially with maths.
I don't know if it's just because,
I don't know if it was
like the education system,
but I would noticed that,
what I learnt was like way
before what Sydney learned
in school sometimes.
I don't know how the
education system works,
but then I also know
that compared to Asian,
Asian schools they are like,
way further beyond whatever
I fucking learned in school.
- Math is everything.
- They were doing like college
level maths in high school.
And I was just like, "What!"
- Yeah, like in Japanese schools
you learn long division
at like fourth grade.
And I'm like, "What?
I didn't learn that till I was like 16."
- What the fuck is long division?
- Long division is like
divide 72,463 by 273.
- That's so shit though,
'cause everyone use calculators nowadays.
You don't need to fucking know this shit.
- Did you guys have like
placement tests for math?
- Yeah.
- You did, okay.
- How was it for you?
- Yeah, we had placement.
- Yeah. I mean like how did you place?
I don't remember what it was.
- Were you good at maths?
- I guess maybe yeah, kind of.
I suppose, yeah.
- Where did you place?
- You mean my test? No.
How dare you?
(all laughing)
- What subjects did
you excel at at school?
Like what did you take?
(Meilyne laughing)
- What did I excel at school?
- Were you good at anything in school?
- Yeah, I had 4.0.
- What does that mean? Is that good?
- Sorry, all A's. That's straight A's.
- That's the highest score.
- I always hear they had a 4.0 GPA.
- Okay, it means you had A's.
So I had A's.
- So you were good at school.
- I wouldn't say it's good.
- What are you talking about?
- No, but like people were
getting 4.1's and stuff
because they do like get-
- You can tell she grew
up in an Asian family.
- Well 4.1 is like extra
curricular activities, right?
- I thought 4.0 was the highest?
- It is, but then you can get higher
if you do extracurriculars.
- Every single true crime documentaries
always like, "He was a good kid.
He had a 4.0 GPA, off to Harvard."
- Yeah, until he cut off
that woman's arms and legs.
- Yeah, pretty much. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- I think the highest math
I got to is like Algebra two
because you can choose to stop.
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
- And I just chose to stop
and then fill it with other courses.
- What was like your
favorite subject in school?
- Favorite subject?
- Yeah.
- Art.
- Art was cool.
- Maybe. Yeah.
I got to make like pasta sculptures.
I loved art because I would
ask my fellow art students.
- All I can imagine is
fucking macaroni art.
- Yeah.
- Are schools like
well-funded where you're from?
- I would say yeah,
well Bay Area is pretty.
- Everything in the
Bay Area's well funded.
(all laughing)
- All the parents donate money.
- Oh wow!
- Oh okay.
- Like one of my aunts
constantly is donating money
to her daughter's school
because it just makes
the program much better.
The government's not giving enough money,
so the neighborhood parents
are just giving money.
- Wow! I remember when
I did like badminton,
there was only like 2 rackets out of 30
that weren't broke.
- That's just like school equipment,
school facilities.
- The wiring is fucked on the nets
to the point where it's like,
you just can't play badminton properly.
- Yeah, we had like 40 acoustic guitars
and only two of them worked. (laughs)
- Oh my God!
- Don't fucking get me
started on textbooks.
Like when the fucking teacher says,
"All right, time to
get out the textbooks."
I'm like, "Who am I sharing with today?"
- Like you're all huddles
around one desk, right?
- Yeah 'cause like in my school,
when you were reading from a textbook,
everyone needed to share
at least with one person.
So everyone had a partner,
like a textbook partner.
- Really?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. We had that.
But not by obligations
because like 1/2 the class
had just forgotten their textbooks.
So it just became like
a tradition to be like,
it's my turn now.
- Do you have cooking classes in America?
- Yeah we have cooking classes.
It's like home ec or something.
- We had cooking class as well.
- I never took it because I hated.
- Oh, we had no choice.
- Oh really?
- Did you have to cook in school?
- Nope.
- They made us cook.
- We had to do it for one year, yeah.
- They made us cook and they made us,
you won't believe what
one of the dishes was,
we'd prepare a sandwich.
(Meilyne laughs)
That was no joke, one of them.
- British cuisine be like.
(all laughing)
- Is it like a tuna melt?
- No, no. Literally your bog
standard lunchbox sandwich.
And when I told my mum,
she had to buy me ingredients to make it.
She was so insulted that she
complained to the school.
- I would be 'cause
that's a waste of an hour.
- She was like, "I'm
not buying ingredients
so you can make a fucking sandwich."
(all laughing)
- I'll make you a fucking
sandwich right now.
- How about I just make one.
(all laughing)
I made a quiche and I think it turned out
to be an omelet or something.
- That's common.
- Yeah, I think certainly that happened
and I was like, "I'm never cooking again."
- Yeah, just anything that uses egg turns
into a different egg dish,
just halfway through
the process every time.
- I don't like that many egg dishes.
- This video is sponsored by Manscaped.
It's time to bundle up
with the Manscaped 4.0
performance package.
Inside this package,
you'll find the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer,
weed whacker ear and nose hair trimmer,
crop ball preserver, crop reviver toner,
performance boxer briefs,
and a travel bag to hold all your goodies.
First off the new performance package,
4.0 includes the new lawnmower 4.0,
if you're looking to cozy up this fall,
this trimmer is essential.
Their fourth generation trimmer features
a cutting edge ceramic blade
to reduce grooming accidents.
Thanks to their advanced
skincare, TM technology.
It also gives you the ability to turn
the 4,000 K LED spotlight on and off
when needed for a more precise shave.
Plus it's waterproof.
The performance package for 4.0
also includes the weed whacker.
The nose and ear hair
trimmer uses a 9,000 RPM,
motor-powered 360 degree
rotary blade system
to provide proprietary
skin safe TM technology,
which helps prevent nicks, snags,
and tugs in those delicate places.
Manscaped even threw in two gifts
to their performance
package 4.0 this time.
The Manscaped TM boxers
and the shed travel bag.
Get comfy on the home and
on the go this season.
Get 20% off plus free
shipping with the code
trashtaste@manscaped.com,
That's 20% off plus free shipping
with the code trashtaste@manscape.com.
Choose Manscaped and your
balls will thank you.
- Americans.
- (laughing) Americans.
- Americans annoy me way
more than other foreigners
though I would say.
- That's on camera.
- Oh.
(all laughing)
- Why do Americans annoy you
than any other foreigner?
- Okay the ones in Japan at least,
a lot of the ones that
complain about being in Japan.
Like, "I hate Japan.
Oh, they're so racist or
no one wants to sit next
to me in the bus."
- Yeah.
- And they just had this
horrible experience in Japan.
And they're mostly, I'm not saying,
all English teachers are
like this but a lot of time,
they are English teachers who are being.
They stay as English teachers for years
and they dream of being
in a different position
or different job.
- Yeah.
- But they're just like
all this, "I hate Japan.
America's the best."
But why don't you go back to America?
But they don't. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- Being an English teacher in
Japan anyway seems like hell.
- Do they complain more than us?
- Yeah.
(Garnt laughing)
- Wow.
- Wow!
- Different types of complaints though.
And they're usually
generally very negative.
- When I complain,
I'm very much understand
where a lot of them come from.
- But off camera you
guys are always praising
how amazing Japan is.
- Don't tell them.
- Don't expose us.
- Oh yeah, I'm so sorry.
- That's our entire brand Meilyne.
Oh my Go!
- Wow!
- You're absolute slander.
- Do we praise Japan a lot off camera?
- Not praise, but like you
guys seem to be enjoying.
- That's why we're here right?
- Yeah.
- It's not because we enjoy being here.
- You exude this positive energy
being here.
- I would be fucking bored
in the UK. Well what would I do in the UK?
- Yeah.
- Oh, "Hey guys, can we go to a bar."
- There's different countries.
- Can I go to a pub.
- And tomorrow I'm
gonna go to another pub.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- For all the slander I've given it,
if I did have to move anywhere,
I'd probably go to America.
- Really?
- Really.
- Yeah, you'd probably live in a country
you weren't born and raised in is fun.
It doesn't matter whether
it's Japan or not.
- It's stimulating.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'd love to live in America
for a short period of time.
- See, 'cause I'd like to live in Europe.
- Really?
- I want to live in Europe.
- I'm bored of Europe.
- I'd like to live somewhere
else in Asia probably.
I don't know.
I just really vibe with Asian
culture and Asian mentality.
- Not that we have any plans
on moving soon. (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's just hypothetical.
- It's the hypothetical.
- Hypothetically.
- If you were like Connor,
you have to get out of Japan,
you're being deported,
which country do you want to move to?
I'm like, "I'll go to America for a bit."
- What do you consider when you wanna move
to another country?
Is it like weather?
- I don't give a fuck about the weather.
- For me it's about whether I just vibe
with the way of living.
- With the culture, right?
- Opportunities, as well.
- As much as I like America,
I personally don't think I could vibe
with the American way of life.
Just personally.
- Yeah.
- What is the "American way of life?"
- I don't know. It's just like.
- I think I'd be a great American.
(Joey laughing)
- You would.
- I think I'd be a
fucking amazing American.
- I think you would.
- I like going in America,
I like American friends,
I like being in America
when I visit but like-
- Yeah.
- When I envision myself
living in America,
I just don't see it.
I don't know what it is.
It's just the vibe about it.
- As you grow older you've
realized that sometimes
you just like subconsciously
jive with some things.
And like there's a difference
going there for holiday
and actually living there.
And I think we've all
experienced this in Japan,
where coming here on
holiday and visiting here,
and actually experiencing
and living the culture here,
is totally different.
What'd you do, Meilyne?
- Spill some tea on the mic.
- I spilled some tea and
then I forgot to swallow
and then it was gonna spill out.
So I was having a crisis. (laughs)
- Need some tissue?
- It's fine.
It landed on my shirt.
- No, I agree though.
I find that socially,
in America sometimes I'm
just like utterly confused.
- Yeah.
- Well, I just don't understand
the person I'm talking to.
They'll just say things and I'm like,
"Why would you say that?"
In the UK I'd never to get that.
It's like there's a script
almost everyone follows.
- Yeah.
- Which is kind of boring
though at the same time
but it's comforting.
- It sounds like it gets
monotonous though, right?
After a while.
- Yeah.
When I go to America,
it's always interesting.
Like you never have a dull moment.
I feel like I'm very easy to approach.
- And you're also an extrovert, right?
- Yeah, I guess so.
- Like for me, whenever
I go back to America,
Japan has like made me
more of an introvert.
So when I go order some food,
and then the register person is like,
"Huh, how are you doing?
Oh, where are you from?"
- Like trying to small talk.
- I'm just like, "Please
stop talking to me.
I just want my burger,
stop talking to me."
And I start sweating,
and then I hate that.
But then you would love that,
'cause you know you like the chatter.
- I want that minimal interaction.
- Well 'cause for me like that
kind of stranger friendliness
that you get from Americans in America,
I've experienced 20 plus
years of that in Australia.
- Yeah.
- So it's like no different to me.
It's just, "Oh, you have a funny accent."
- Still but Australia's
so far from everything.
- Yeah, also everything wants to kill you.
- But the food is so delicious.
- Yeah, you were frothing over the food.
- So if you're saying
the food's delicious,
then I got to check this out.
How many Google reviews did you do?
- Like four.
- Four. (laughs)
- We didn't have that much time.
- How hard is it to get
good internet in Austria?
- It's gotten a lot better in the past,
since I've moved out here.
- Really? Okay.
- Like if you go to like
Melbourne or Sydney,
they actually have good
internet speeds now.
Finally, after all this time,
of course they had to do it right
when I fucking left the country.
- Honestly, I think I could really jive
with the Australian culture
from what I've seen.
- It's so far from everything.
Everyone is at least a 12
hour flight minimum from you.
- It is but like how often
are you flying out.
- Why do you think Australians
love traveling? (laughs)
- yeah, yeah.
- Exactly, right.
Australians are like fucking
everywhere especially in Asia.
- Yeah.
- Everywhere.
- Can't get fucking rid of them.
(all laughing)
- They're invading San Diego apparently.
- Huh?
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Why San Diego?
- I don't know.
A few of my San Diego friends told me,
they're like, "There's so
many Australians here."
- She says after meeting
one Australian. (laughs)
- Well, when I was growing up though,
I always thought America
was way cooler than the UK.
I just thought.
- That's just because
you were born in the UK.
- To be fair growing up,
I thought pretty much anywhere
else was cooler than the UK.
- The UK. Right?
It's like, our image is on borrowed time.
- Yeah.
- What the UK actually is and
what people think the UK is,
is entirely different things.
- It's starting to catch up with us now,
in our lifetime.
- When I was growing up,
everyone still thought the British people
were like charming and sexy.
- Yeah.
- Everyone was like, "Oh
my God, he's British.
Oh my gosh. Oh."
And then now it's like
Tuesday, bottle of water.
That's all I get now.
(Joey laughing)
And that's what I always recognized.
- Now we'll just get clowned
on by everyone including us.
And I'm just like, "No, no, no.
We clown on ourselves.
You can't clown on us."
- The UK has very picturesque things,
has very nice and elegant
things but unfortunately,
it's stones.
- The buildings.
- I love a lot about-
- The materials.
- Oh like the stone buildings?
Is that what you're talking about?
- Yeah, sorry.
- I love a lot about-
- The architecture?
(all laughing)
- There we go. There it is.
- That's the word we're all looking for.
- I love the bricks.
(all laughing)
- No, no. In my mind,
I was zooming in on the image
of just one of the brick.
- Right.
(Joey laughs)
A stone wall type of thing.
- A single brick.
- Yeah, and I was like.
- The UK has nice bricks, yeah.
- It was nice. The UK was nice.
I feel like it's gone downhill
a lot since the old days.
- Like the sheep running
through the fields.
- The good old days.
- Not the days where I was born,
before me it looked
like it was pretty cool.
I don't know if that's
because I wasn't born there,
yet, but,
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Oh, maybe I don't know
I feel like some things
were just cooler before we were born.
I feel like, the stereotype about,
music was better in my
parents days or but you know,
when your parents said that.
I think that's actually kind of true.
I think I would love to have
lived in my parents' age
with some of the fucking bands and stars
that they listened to.
- Yeah but at the same
time you think about it
and it's like, "All right,
well there's no internet.
There's no iPhone, there's
no anything like that."
Like that sounds pretty crappy honestly
when you think about it.
Now that you know the
whole handiness of today.
- You assimilate with
whatever you have at the time.
Right? You get used to it.
- Yeah of course.
- Even if you had no phone,
you'd get used to it.
- You enjoy other things.
- Yeah, whatever.
- But do you think kids
30, 40 years from now,
will be saying the same
thing about the 20's?
- No, no, no. The UK-
- They're all in 20's.
- It's very unfortunate
'cause I feel like,
coming from like up north,
like everything in the UK
was kind of like focused
on London and the south,
and the common sentiment
from where I grew up
and around the area is
kind of like abandoned,
all the money and stuff
and all the investment went to London.
- Yeah.
- So a lot of the north
Northern cities in the UK
have kind of been deprived of any
economical advantages or anything.
And so, a lot of the cities
are kind of getting run down.
It's not very good.
- It's kind of like Japan, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- Very much so.
But unfortunately it's like,
I feel like at least in
the countryside of Japan,
it's like, all right well,
at least they can still
do the local business
of farming and stuff.
In some certain UK towns, just nothing.
There's like nothing to do.
- How do you make money in those areas?
- It's all like minimum wage jobs.
And there's no like big business there.
- Or, it's either like you
commute to the bigger city.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I was thinking about this earlier
and I think as we grow older,
we will be able to say that we did grow up
in a pretty cool time
actually because we have,
I was thinking like what
would be interesting
to like a younger
generation to hear about.
And I think the fact that
we grew up in the age
where basically internet was invented,
I think that will be cool.
I think that'll be cool as fuck to say.
- We're like the last
generation of people really
who grew up initially
without a smartphone.
- Yeah.
- It wasn't like till like age like-
- 13 I think.
- Imagine saying to your grandchild,
"Let me tell you when the internet
just was assimilated into society."
I think that's a cool
fucking story because like-
- We grew up in like the
fucking VCR, DVD era.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Which is like ancient
technology to kids today.
They are like, "Wait, what the fuck's?"
Like kids really don't know what a VCR is.
I'm like, have I really
gotten to that point now
where I'm just like, "Oh,
you fucking youths of today
don't even know what a VCR is.
You never had to like stick the pencil in
to like rewind the tape."
- Let me tell you about
LimeWire and Napster.
(all laughing)
Let me tell you the war stories,
of how to download
Lincoln Park Of Webster.
(Joey laughing)
Had to download Lincoln park
and got fucking Bill Clinton
for the 50 millionth time.
(Joey laughing)
- The question though,
when did you guys get your first
cell phones or smartphones?
- I entered high school.
- High school?
- 13.
- Yeah, I was 13. Yeah.
- My parents didn't
want me to get bullied.
They really didn't want
to get me a smartphone,
but everyone else had a smartphone.
- What was your first phone?
- It was essentially a Nokia brick.
- Yeah, mine was a Nokia flip phone.
I couldn't even get a Nokia.
I always got like a knockoff.
- Well, this was at
the time when the Sony,
like the Walkman phone had come out.
And so that was like the shit.
And there's like the flip Sony,
and that was like the big boy.
- Now for us in Australia
was the Motorola razor.
- Oh, those ones.
- Yeah.
- All the cool kids
had the Motorola razor.
- Yeah, yeah.
- This is back when you couldn't
play video on your phone.
So that was the phone I had.
- Was just texting basically.
- And it was supposed to
be for emergencies only,
but we didn't text each
other because it was,
it was 10 pence to send a text.
- Yeah that's right.
- The texting plans?
All you can text?
- No. They didn't exist back in the day.
- Texting your friend
was like an urgent thing.
But at that time as well,
when you had those phones,
MSN messenger was a thing as well.
So you'd never text
because you would just go.
- You just got home and message on MSN.
- The only time I think
I ever texted someone
was when like we said
we're gonna meet at a place
and I was there and I couldn't find them.
And I was like, "Where are you?"
'Cause calling was too expensive'
- Yeah.
- 'Cause calling was like
10, 20 Pence a minute.
- Yeah, exactly.
If you press the call button,
you're just like, "This
is a fucking emergency."
- This is an investment.
(Joey laughing)
- Like my God, someone
must be fucking dying next
to me for you to be making a call, man.
What is going on?
- I got the phone under the
condition of emergencies only.
- Yeah.
- What about you?
- I don't remember exactly.
Probably the same age.
I was just curious.
- Did you go straight to iPhone
or did you get like the flip phone?
- No, I had a flip phone,
but it was like non flip phone.
And then I got the flip.
- Like the bricks right?
- Yeah, I think it was a brick.
- Like with the little
antenna on top. (laughs)
- No.
- The old Nokia's have that
little like knob at the top,
which was like the antenna.
- Oh yeah, that one. That one yeah.
- Were you a gamer growing up?
- Wait, what? (laughs)
- Yeah, obviously she played "MapleStory."
- I've played other
games than "MapleStory."
- What other games did you play?
- "Dory, Flyff for Fun."
- What the hell was that?
- What the fuck is that?
- Flyff? It's like you learn
to fly in the game. (laughs)
I don't know. It's like Maple story,
but then you can level
up your flying ability.
(all laughing)
- So it's a maple story expansion pack?
- What console is the on?
- [Camera Man] It's on PC.
- Pc. I played a lot of PC games.
- Did you ever own a game console?
- Yeah, I do. I own all of them.
- What's your favorite console game?
- Console game?
- What's your favorite console?
- PlayStation probably.
- Which one?
- 1, 2, 3, 4?
- Well. Two.
I really liked the "Lord
of the Rings" games.
"King Arthur."
- They're good games.
"Lord of the Rings" games on PS2.
- They're pretty good.
- Yeah they are pretty good.
- Played them in like quite a bit.
- But you're more of
an anime person, right?
Obviously you-
- Don't bring anime into this Garnt.
- (laughs) I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry you're trying
to bring gaming into this.
(Garnt laughing)
- Gaming is fun too.
- The "Dichotomy of Man."
See you gamer.
- So let me do the middle ground then.
Did you play any like anime games?
- Isn't maple story an anime game?
- Well that's more like a
game that has anime aesthetic,
but it's not like.
- Okay, visual novel type game right?
- Oh Gosh!
- I played Half Caucasian since
like the dating simulations.
- Oh yeah.
- Of course you did. That's how it starts.
- Everyone she completed,
she bought a new body part.
(all laughing)
- Yeah. 'Cause I got to ask.
How the fuck did the body
pillow addiction start?
How did that side of
you start at all? Right?
- I don't know. I like pillows.
- No, no. I like pillows.
There was a big difference
in liking a good pillow
and a body pillow.
- Yeah.
- Okay, I was obsessed with PS2.
I didn't really like people,
like male species.
Just kidding now. (laughs)
so I'm just kidding.
- Wow! Wow!
- We're having a good time.
- Rich coming from you female.
- I'm so sorry.
I wasn't attracted to like,
human men.
- Real people.
- You wanted to 3D?
- Yeah.
- You can just say that you want it to 3D.
- Humans!
- And the way that 2D characters look,
were just so pretty and I needed
something lifelike because.
- What was the first
like anime or whatever,
that got you into the 2D world,
that made you give up on humanity,
(all laughing)
that made you reject humanity.
- "Hakuoki."
- Oh, the Shinzengumi one.
- Shinzengumi, police force.
- Haul it back to
Meilyne's three by three.
- Yeah. Go watch that clip.
- Yeah.
- I don't know, it's just
the exposure of their chest.
(Meilyne laughing)
- And yet now you're
like allergic to nipple.
- It's different, they don't show nipple.
- 'Cause it's 3D.
- They always censor nipple.
- That's right, that's right.
- That's why she can't see
real nipple because in anime,
nipples just don't exist for some reason.
- The next time you guys,
any of you guys come to my house
or maybe I'll bring a
pillow or something here,
the naked ones,
they don't have the nipples.
It's just the chest.
- Did they do that on purpose?
- I think so.
- Or is that how you learn?
- I should probably clear Meilyne
is scared of male nipples.
- Yeah, yeah.
(Meilyne laughs)
- Oh yeah, Meilyne.
- Unless it's her husband's.
- Apart from her husband,
Meilyne is like terrified
of like male nipples.
- It's 'cause you know
when you don't wanna stare
at something but then
you just end up looking,
and then.
(all laughing)
Hold on, wait!
- Oh God! Continue, continue.
- And I just feel like
it's staring into my soul
and I just feel uncomfortable.
- So in other words you
don't stare at the nipple.
The nipple stares you back.
(all laughing)
- Yes,
and I don't wanna confirm.
- And you don't want that eye contact.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- Oh my God!
- So your husband was 2D like?
- Yeah.
- Does your husband have nipples?
- Wait, wait. The 2D one or something?
(all laughing)
I used to do a ranking.
Like my 2D, I would have
husband, ex-husband,
boyfriend, ex-boyfriend rankings.
- Does your husband feel intimidated
by all of your body pillows?
- No. He says something really weird.
Wait, nevermind. Forget it.
(all laughing)
- No you can't just tease us like that.
Go on, go on.
- I can't.
- Is it bad?
- Yeah, it's pretty bad.
I'll tell you guys after.
He says weird stuff a lot.
- Yeah, he does.
- Yeah we know.
- I feel like some of it rubs onto you
because like you're saying
something super weird,
but when we're just doing like
the normal things sometimes.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like that didn't
come from you. (laughs)
Can I tell them,
what you said about drinking water?
That's like, no.
- What?
- Okay.
- Like what?
- When you see like anime
characters drinking water.
- Oh, okay.
There's this character I used to like,
are you talking about the taste?
Oh. Okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So one of the characters
that I used to like,
or still like, oh my God I'm
dripping everywhere. (laughs)
- When she talks about anime guys, right.
(all laughing)
- I'm like shaking when I talk about it.
- Oh my God!
- So, Juji Wen, his color's orange,
everything about him is orange.
He smells orange and sometimes,
or if he's eating orange and you know,
you just wanna know what they're eating.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Wait, does he canonically
smell like oranges?
- No, no, no. She said the
weirdest thing to me. Right?
Because she was talking
about her obsession
with 2D anime guys. Right?
And she was just like, "Dude,
did you ever see like a waifu
or like one of your waifu's
and you saw them drinking something
and you wanted to drink the same thing."
And I was just like, "No,
why did you wanna do that?"
And I just thought so you could taste
what they're tasting. Right?
And she goes to me, "Oh yeah."
'Cause they just sometimes
you just wanna know
what the inside of their mouth feels like.
So you drink the same thing.
(Meilyne laughing)
(all laughing)
- I'm like actually scared.
I'm glad I'm sitting
this distance with you.
- If you were a guy and you said that,
everyone would be like, "Wow!"
- You'd be immediately canceled. (laughs)
- What a pathetic man,
what a weird man.
(Joey laughing)
- It's that correct to what you said?
- They sometimes have commercials in Japan
where that character is endorsing this,
and then you drink it too.
And then you always think about them
'cause that's what they're drinking.
- Does your husband feel like
he's competing sometimes?
- No, no.
I was also in long distance
with my husband boyfriend at the time.
So like he would drink
coffee and then I'll be like,
"Oh, every time I drink coffee
it's kind of like." (laughs)
- You're kissing?
(all laughing)
- Is that it?
- Finish the sentence,
finish the sentence.
- It's not so much kissing
as it's more tasting
the inside of his mouth.
- Every time he pees, I pee.
It's like we're peeing
into each other.
- It's like we're peeing
together, it's like
we're crossing streams.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- I understand that.
- Yeah, but like if someone's single
and they really like 2D characters,
and you see your 2D character
eating a cake or something,
I definitely recommend it.
- It's called immersion.
- Yeah.
- It's called immersion?
- It's like people who are watching this,
and they're drinking coffee too.
It's the same. Oh no, nevermind.
- What?
- He's always just like,
"Yeah, Meilyne is weird."
(all laughing)
That's what he says.
- Yeah, we know.
We know man.
- Do you remember what he
said to you on your birthday?
- What did he say to me?
- About Sidney,
and Sidney told me,
what Markey said,
"Oh, I'm glad someone
understands or something?"
- What?
- My husband told you,
"Oh, I'm glad I found someone."
- I'm glad I found someone because
both our partners are crazy.
(all laughing)
- No, they were just
sitting next to each other.
I think you were in the corner somewhere.
- Just having like a bro talk.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- I gotta come clean man.
- And they started laughing out loud.
And I was like, wonder what
they're laughing about.
- Because Sydney and Meilyne
hang out all the time.
And sometimes it's just like,
the perfect storm.
You know in perfect storm
where you have two hurricanes
and they mix and then they form-
- Turnings of one super hurricane.
- like one super massive hurricane.
That's just whenever Sidney
and Meilyne hang together.
- It's because we drink too much I think.
- You just feed off each
other's chaotic energy.
And they just like start saying the most
like cursed shit you will ever hear.
- You ever heard something then
your husband would be like,
"She's crazy."
(Garnt laughing)
- He just says that.
So that you think he's normal too.
- Maybe, yeah.
- That is true.
- Yeah.
- She's still addicted to "Apex?"
- Oh yes. (laughs)
Did you ever say that?
- No, I haven't told that story.
- Oh yeah, I don't know.
- Oh my God!
- We were at Meilyne's
house having a gathering.
- Yeah.
- No it was after I think you went home.
- Yeah. Joey I think it was
actually on my birthday.
It was my birthday.
- It was your birthday, yeah.
- It all goes back to that
because a lot of things
happened there.
So Joey had to go home early
'cause he had to film the next day.
- Yeah.
- So we're at Meilyne's,
I guess just chilling
until like 2:00, 4:00 AM.
- Yeah.
- I remember at 2:00 AM
I'm just like having a chat
with Meilyne, and then I look over.
Fucking Connor kind of takes the control
of Meilyne's husband and he's like,
"You need to play this game."
He downloads "Apex," for Markey.
I'm just like, "Oh for fucks sake."
- Yeah. He plays every day.
- You've poisoned the world.
- I went to his house, got the PS5.
I installed "Apex."
I was like, "Would you wait now,
we'll have so much fun."
He was showing me these games on PS5.
And I'm like, "This is terrible.
These games are terrible.
Let me show you a real game.
It's free to download.
Let me download it right now."
I downloaded it,
and then I just thought
that maybe he would play it
a few times and then be done.
But he's like addicted.
- Yeah he plays every day, every day.
And I'll be in a call and he
doesn't use his headphones,
so the walls will be, (booms)
(all laughing)
And I'm just like, "Hi
did you hear that Randall?
I'm so sorry."
- Sorry, that's just the AK 47.
(all laughing)
- And so this was awesome
to complete the story
we started like literally
I think like a fucking hour ago.
So we start watching fucking
Connor teaching Markey,
how to play "Apex." Right?
- Yeah.
- And then this is like
3:00, 4:00 AM at this point.
And we are obviously at
this point intoxicated.
Now, you know when you're intoxicated,
maybe sometimes you get
cravings, you get cravings.
Mostly people crave, maybe pizza,
sometimes some people crave, a pizza.
Obviously not you.
Maybe people crave a
kebab, a burger maybe,
a burger, go to local chippy or something.
Get a chicken burger or whatever.
So Meilyne' is just sitting
there and she's just like,
"I feel like Nigerian beef stew."
And I was like, (laughs)
"What do you mean?"
- That's very strange.
- Where did you get this craving from?
And she was like, "I'm gonna
cook Nigerian beef stew,
right now."
I was like, "Who has
this craving at 3:00 AM
in the morning?"
- It just sounds like a scripted
event from a game, right?
- I've never heard of
Nigerian beef stew in my life.
- So you're hearing it for
the first time at 3:00am.
- Yeah. Sometimes Meilyne does
talk like an oblivion MPC.
(all laughing)
- What is an oblivion MPC?
- It's a game in PC.
- I don't even know
how I'd begin to explain it.
- I feel like such a boomer. (laughs)
- You sound like a video
game MPC, in other words.
- There's always so many things
you're like, "What is POG?
What is busing?"
- I know what POG is,
or busing.
- I know busing. (laughs)
- I know you young people speak.
- Yeah.
'Cause like the reason I bring this up
is because it's like she just,
had all the fucking ingredients
for Nigerian beef stew,
at 3:00 AM and I'm just like.
- It's so simple.
- Is it?
- It was fucking dark.
- it wasn't dark
so I don't know the color of it.
- Meilyne will give you like something.
- I don't know that color.
- Meilyne will present
me like a god-tier dish.
I'm at 4:00 AM.
- Most of the lights off but
only the disco lights are on.
- I'm very angry, I'll
fucking eat anything.
- You made the Nigerian beef
stew under disco lights?
(all laughing)
- Yeah, I got this $5 light.
- It was so surreal just
seeing Meilyne in the dark.
- Meilyne at the club
making a Nigerian beef stew.
- No, it was like bizarre amazing.
- And she's just like, "let
me pull up my spice rack."
- No, 'cause someone was sleeping
and I didn't wanna wake them up.
- Handing out all my disco
homies Nigerian beef stew
at the club.
- 'Cause you also grow
like Carolina reapers
and stuff as well.
- And ghost peppers.
- And yeah, you gave them out to people.
- Yeah.
- And they were struggling.
- Where'd you learn how to cook
or do you just like
follow YouTube recipes?
- I don't follow,
I just watch a bunch of
cooking things constantly.
- Do you like, do you like
watch Gordon Ramsey videos?
- No, I used to, not anymore.
That was like TV days.
- Jamie Oliver?
- Gordon Ramsey is more entertainment
than educational.
- Yeah. Yeah.
But nowadays there's so
many different sources,
on YouTube and I just, like Food Wishes.
- One thing I've noticed
about a lot of top chefs
whenever they do like cooking videos,
it's like they always add
so much fucking olive oil.
I don't know what it is
about fucking olive oil.
You see a celebrity chef add olive oil,
and just like, "Just a
little touch of olive oil."
And they fucking invade
Italy in the process.
I swear to God, man.
(all laughing)
- I love the-
- Smash cuts with olive field.
(air whooshing)
(Garnt laughing)
- So just a little dollop of olive oil.
- One teaspoon of olive oil.
It's like a whole genre of videos, right?
There is like absolutely
fucking God awful,
like cocktail recipes.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- And not intentional and some of them
are literally just like
full bottles of alcohol,
like spirits.
- Is that the two shots of vodka thing?
- It's kind of like
that but taking too far,
like I was watching a video,
and there's this woman telling
you how to make a drink?
And it was a cocktail.
She put like two leaves of coriander in,
a bunch of shaved ice,
And then she just poured like
a whole bottle of Bacardi,
into this thing to fill it up.
And she's like, "And there you go,
you have your."
And she named the drink,
I can't remember what it was called.
And it was just like,
"What the fuck is this?"
This is just straight Bacardi.
This isn't a drink.
It was like a pint glass as well.
I was like, "What the fuck,
this is a hospital booking.
(Joey laughing)
What is this?
I got to show you guys.
I'm going to show you some
of these fucking cocktails,
abominations.
- I've never seen that.
- That's not even a cocktail,
they didn't mix it with anything.
- There's no mixer.
It's just like some
fucking flowers and shit
and a whole bottle of Jack Daniels.
That's it.
(all laughing)
It's terrible.
- Essence of the stuff that they put in.
- It's still not a mixer though.
It's still not a mixer.
- Who's your favorite YouTuber, Meilyne?
- That's not us.
- Obviously, we pay the bills.
- Or "Trash Taste."
- You can't say us.
- Do you even watch a lot of YouTube.
- I do. I watch a lot
of food related YouTube
or anime related.
- Do you watch "Report of the Week?"
- Sometimes.
- Seriously?
- Do you like him?
- Do I like him?
- Do you like his videos?
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
I don't watch all the time.
It's like once every two months.
- I'm a big fan, I watch every video.
- You guys watch a lot though you have to.
- We're like YouTubers, right?
That's that's part of
the job to watch YouTube.
- Are you a YouTuber?
- We are YouTubers.
It's just part of the job
to watch a lot of YouTube.
And I don't know if that's
just like warped my experience
'cause I don't know how
much YouTube everyone
else watches anymore.
Do you find that?
Sometimes I talk to someone
and now I just assume,
they are also as versed
with like YouTube culture
and YouTube videos as I am.
- I always get reminded
that I'm way too deep
into YouTube and memes.
When I say a meme,
or I reference a meme,
that is so in-depth in meme
culture that it requires
like knowledge of like
seven previous memes.
- Yeah.
- And then knowledge of each
like variation of said meme.
- Yeah.
- Those memes are tough.
(all laughing)
That's when I really feel like fuck,
I'm not sweating.
Because also some memes they
are funny if you get it.
But like when you're trying to describe
like peepee poopoo stinky,
it's like there's no way of
describing that meme to someone,
without showing the video,
without also sounding like
a complete fucking idiot.
- I'm glad you talked to me
like a normal English level.
Not with like the mamey stuff.
- What do you mean?
- Like if I were to say that's busing mum,
she'd be like, "What is busing?"
- I have that reaction sometimes of you.
I'm gonna say, I think
busing is an awful word.
- I love busing, man.
(Garnt laughing)
Busing is such a, it's got such mm.
- Busing!
- Busing. (laughing)
I get it. I feel passionate
when I say busing.
(Joey laughs)
- It wouldn't feel right
for me to say like busing.
- Why wouldn't it feel right
to say it?
- Well because you're not
saying it with confidence.
- You gotta get comfortable with it.
- You gotta be confident.
You gotta put some base
behind it like busing.
- Fucking hell.
- My cheeks tense up before
I can even say it right.
- (laughing) You trying
to say it's busing.
- It's busing.
- So wait, who is your
favorite YouTuber, sorry?
- Oh, Japan would be like Kimagure Cook.
- I love him.
- I just love the way
he cuts into the fish.
- Kimagure Cook he's pretty big.
He's like top 10 Japanese
YouTubers I think.
But like he basically just
dissects a shitload of fish.
- Well he cooks them also.
- Is this the guy who killed the frog?
- No, no, no, no. That's different.
That's like the shit-
- That was the saddest thing-
- That frog video.
- There was like a video
on how to prepare a frog.
And I think Meilyne showed me.
- Oh yeah, that just like
fucking chops it in half.
- I think we were at an Izakaya.
- No, no, no. 'Cause I
remember 'cause like this,
like sometimes because
Meilyne gets recommended
so many food videos.
- Do you like the weird
had cooking videos as well,
where you have to like destroy animals.
- (laughing) Destroy animals.
- What do you mean destroy animals?
- I feel like saying preparing the frog
doesn't do it justice.
- It doesn't.
- 'Cause that's not what happened.
The guy like cuts this frog in half
and you hear bones crunching.
- He doesn't prepare the frog,
he massacres the frog.
- Like Robot Wars.
(Joey laughing)
But like a man.
- I feel like I just
watched fucking "Saw" seven.
We're not gonna put it up a screen.
I'm like, "If you're squeamish,
we're not gonna talk about it too much
because I still think about it.
I'm not like a squeamish person,
but I felt so bad for the frog.
- It's a brutal video.
- It's a fucking brutal video.
- That was okay because
he's going to eat it.
He wasn't doing it for fun.
- Yeah I know it is.
- Oh no, of course not.
- I recognize there's
nothing wrong with it
'cause he's gonna eat it.
It's no more brutal than
killing a cow or something.
- It's educational.
- Right. Right.
I guess it's just because you don't,
it's not everyday you see
a guy chop a frog in half.
- Yeah.
- To prepare some.
- Unless you're in Thailand or Vietnam.
- 'Cause the thing is,
you never really think
about how animals die
before they're cooked.
They get killed.
We're lucky enough to not have to do it
ourselves a lot of the times.
That's what it's like to grow
up in a civilized society.
Right. So when I see a full fucking-
- Are we even civilized?
- Yeah, when I see a fucking
mortal combat fatality
being put on this frog I'm just like,
"Jesus fucking Christ."
- I was just waiting for like x-ray zoom
from that frog as the
head is getting crushed.
- That one was very violent.
- Yeah. Yeah. Obviously-
- It's a part of you and don't look it up.
- The food being prepared
is generally not that good.
- Yeah. That's why.
- Yeah.
- That's why people turn into vegetarians.
You know?
- Yeah. Yeah.
I wouldn't eat anything
that I wasn't prepared
to kill myself if I had to.
- It doesn't mean I have
to enjoy the process.
- I feel like you're a psychopath,
if you enjoy putting
down an animal to eat it.
- No.
- Yeah, yeah.
(all laughing)
- I meant no as in, yeah no.
No hold on. Hold on. (laughs)
- Do you have something to say Meilyne?
- I meant no as in like, it's bad.
- Yeah, yeah, it's bad.
- Yeah.
- It came out wrong.
- No.
- You said that like no I disagree.
- No, no.
- I like the killing part.
(all laughing)
- I say if you don't
enjoy it what's the point?
- It came out wrong.
I don't kill animals.
- Oh my God!
- I think just bones crunching
is just generally unpleasant.
Do you remember when we
had to like dissect fish
or like cut the bones to
separate parts of the body.
It's often quite,
it doesn't really sound nice.
- I don't enjoy it.
- I don't get much pleasure out of it.
- When it stops moving,
it's like when it feels
a little weird. Right?
- I think it feels weird.
I think it feels weird
when it's still moving.
- Yeah, yeah. That's
when it's weirdest to me.
- Oh, like struggling?
- Yeah.
- Don't say struggling.
- No, no, no.
- Oh God Meilyne.
Oh my God!
- When I buy like live
fish, I don't hold it down.
My husband holds it down,
'cause I can't handle it.
- She's like husband, you
put the blood on your hands.
Not me.
- No 'cause he doesn't want
to be the one to poop it.
- Oh, oh.
- So hold it down.
- So Meilyne, why can't you hold it down?
- Because I can feel its muscles moving.
Like it's struggling.
- Like it's alive.
- But you should be prepared for that,
if you're gonna kill it.
- Yeah. If you're the one like
excitedly holding the knife.
- But he's gonna eat it too.
So we're sharing the burden.
- Oh wow! So when I go to the restaurant,
the chefs would come out.
Nah, I'm not gonna lie
Connor, I'm quite squeamish.
Could you hold down this
cow while I shoot him.
(all laughing)
- You're just blaming the
murder on someone else.
- Yeah, you're just trying.
- It's like we're in this together.
- No, I put the knife in.
- Meilyne is thing like,
"I don't wanna go to hell.
If I get someone else to do it, it'll be."
- Sharing the sin.
- No, I put the knife in.
Okay, I put the knife in.
- Of course when we asked you
for your YouTube recommendations,
we get to see you being a brutal murder.
- No, no. I also watch
like food travel things
like "Best Ever Food Review Show."
- Oh yeah, I like that show.
Yeah, that guy is cool.
- I've been watching for like years.
- Yeah, 'cause like I'm always wondering,
why don't you make your
own YouTube channel?
- She does.
- I do?
- Yeah, I've seen your videos.
- Aside from that one.
'Cause I've seen them.
I've seen them as well.
- That's like four years ago.
- Are we allowed to talk about it?
- About which one?
The one with you like
reviewing the men's body.
- Okay.
(all laughing)
- You in the cosplay.
- No, I wasn't wearing cosplay.
I found this water bottle that
was the shape of a man's body
and it was a IQ character
and then I was seeing,
I saw that it was trending
on Japanese Twitter,
that if you peel off the wrapping,
like the clothes,
and then pour milk tea in,
the naked body appears.
So I was so fascinated that
I wanted to show people that.
- You are literally the epitome
of the heavy breathing cat.
Yeah. (laughing)
Like whenever you see like a 2D male.
- If you were at the after dark tour,
it wasn't actually Nami, it was Meilyne.
- What?
(all laughing)
- Meilyne was very
excited about everything.
- I thought it's a really
interesting concept
with you being such a big Google reviewer.
If you just like,
it's like the road to like the top 5%
or something like that.
- How long will it take?
- Well, Meilyne has a Twitter now,
so you can follow her on there,
you can watch her updates,
but I would love to see
some Meilyne content.
- GourmetMeilyne.
- Main content?
- Would you subscribe?
- Yeah, of course.
- Of course.
- I reckon you'd be really
good at just like food reviews.
- That's 'cause I've never seen someone
so brutal when it comes to
reviewing things as you.
My God like you have no chill.
Some stuff I've heard you say is like,
it's straight to the fucking heart.
- I'll be like, "This was
just the most excellent meal.
I'm extremely satisfied.
Meilyne what did you think?"
And then Meilyne's like,
"It tastes like dirt."
- I don't want people to think
anyone can run a restaurant.
Like in America, a lot of the times,
there's like these Japanese.
- You have single-handedly
deterred me from ever running
my own restaurant.
- Yeah.
- Okay, come on,
you can't compare Japanese restaurants
to American or European restaurants.
- I'm just saying people
will move somewhere,
and then whatever country
they're from they think
they can make the food of their country
and represent the country
with that restaurant.
But it's not that simple.
- No, of course not.
- I know they're trying to make a living.
Just thinking of, I don't know.
- So what are the things you look for,
when you go to a restaurant?
Like what's like the number
one thing of like everything?
Or like the first thing you look at.
- It depends what I'm going for.
If I'm just going for like
Thai or Vietnamese food,
I'm not going to look at how dirty it is.
- How do you weigh each aspect?
So let's say there's five stars,
does like the food get three of the stars,
the service gets one and then there's the.
- Or is it just kind
of a package thing?
- It's just different.
It's a package.
It's like how do I feel when I leave?
Yeah, sometimes I'll think I already know.
- If the food was amazing
but the waiter was rude,
how is that like?
- No, I'll write that.
I would be like, "Oh my God,
the food was so delicious
but it's just unfortunate,
that the service was bad."
- One thing I was speaking
to Chris about this,
and we were talking about,
he was like, "Oh, I don't
wanna say anything bad
about some stuff 'cause I don't wanna like
potentially risk them losing business
or going out of business."
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I said to Chris, I was like,
"If a place is so bad that
you give it one stars,
I genuinely don't deserve
they get to run a restaurant.
- Right.
- I give it to the point where
it could be like food safety.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Or it's just so bad in every single way,
I don't care if someone loses their job.
'Cause they shouldn't be in that job.
- You can just watch
kitchen nightmares. Right?
- You watch that and you're like,
you don't deserve to have this job.
- They disrespect the food and
they disrespect the customer.
- You don't deserve.
- Honestly like sometimes
I go to a restaurant
and I'm just like there's
nothing more disappointing
than going to a restaurant and
just having like a bad meal.
- It's so sad to me.
- My day is literally ruined.
Nothing is worse than a bad meal.
- Yeah, Japan changed that
for Meilyne 'cause in the UK,
it is like a 50/50 coin.
- It is. It is.
- Whether or not the restaurant
is gonna be just good.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Most things are good,
but they're not amazing.
- It's about the little things
in life to look forward to.
And I look forward to just a
good meal at least once a day.
If I have like an amazing
lunch and dinner could be like-
- Yeah.
- I just want one good meal
whether it be home cooked,
or restaurant or wherever,
it doesn't need to be expensive.
It can be expensive, cheap,
I just want a good meal.
And if I'm wasting my daily meal on a bad,
like on a bad restaurant experience,
then my day is literally like.
- It's scam.
- Yeah. I'm just like,
"You took this from me.
You took the only little joy."
- You took my time, my money.
- You took the little
joy I look for every day
and you gave me an awful
meal and I'm just like,
"Yeah, that's just bad."
And sometimes I literally
don't understand sometimes,
how some restaurants can serve bad meals.
- It's sad to me that someone
went through the trouble
of opening up a restaurant to serve shit.
- For seafood restaurants right now,
it's kind of sad for Hokkaido at least.
They're not getting
enough customers to get
new batches of seafood coming in.
So their ratings have dropped
because when the customers
come in and it's like it's not fresh.
Wow! I can't believe this has four stars.
I'm gonna give it two.
It's really sad.
- Yeah. 'Cause like the reason
it blows my mind is that
how can just like myself following
a random YouTube video I found,
I'm just following that recipe.
How can that taste better
than me being served
a restaurant meal,
that has been cooked by a chef right?
- You can master it.
- When you watch kitchen
nightmares it all makes sense.
You're just like, "These
people just want jobs.
They don't want to cook it.
They wanna work."
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah. At that point it's just like,
it's just like why are you
in the restaurant business?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it's not easy to
run a fucking restaurant.
Like you don't have to run a restaurant
to know that that's fucking hard work.
So it's like, "Why would
you spend all that time,
money and effort to then
just get a bunch of people
come into your restaurant,
hate your food, hate your service,
and then leave disappointed."
It's like, "What's the point?"
- Yeah, I think I would
rather my local restaurant
to have more passion than
whoever's doing surgery on me.
I don't really need my surgeon
to be passionate about it.
I need my restaurant tour to be passionate
about what they're doing.
- Yeah.
- Because who cares about
doing open heart surgery?
I don't care about that.
He probably doesn't care about that.
- Probably the person getting under.
- The person getting
under the fucking skull.
- It probably doesn't
mean shit if then you get
the surgery you live and then you go
to a shit restaurant afterwards.
What's the point?
(Joey laughing)
So to me it's way more important that
there are some jobs that need passion.
- You say that as if you
have open heart surgery,
as often as you have a meal.
There's a bit of a different story.
- Even then I would still rather,
him be dispassionate about it.
There's some jobs I'm like,
"You do need to be
passionate about this job."
Restaurant is one of those jobs.
- Oh no, definitely.
Restaurant's like sometimes it just,
you can just feel the passion
coming out of the meal.
Right?
- Yeah.
- And from the people running it.
Those are the best meals.
- Yeah, 100%. 100%.
- Do you like it when the
chef comes out and asks you
like, "How did you like it?"
- I love it.
That shows to me, he cares.
- He cares. Yeah.
- 'Cause this isn't just me
he's probably doing it too.
- Yeah, obviously it's shit over here.
(all laughing)
I shake his hand, I get the meal for free.
I'm just kidding.
Obviously he's doing
that to like everyone.
- 'Cause he cares.
- Yeah, that means a lot.
- Now I like that.
- Where they'll ask you
which dish did you like?
Which one was a miss, hit or missed?
- Yeah, where did we go
recently where that happened?
- The Italian place.
- Why, what happened?
- They asked us what dish.
- I swear I got asked
somewhere recently. I got asked.
- Oh, I wasn't with you.
- It was with us where we
were sitting at the counter.
It was the steak place we went to,
the Italian steak place,
where we get the aged steak.
- Oh, yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Which place?
- The one where we get the
45 or 48 day aged stake.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- We've all been there.
- You've been there like three times.
- It's a counter seat,
they have an open ground.
- We took Chris there.
- Yeah.
- Oh, oh. That place!
(Garnt laughing)
- It's like how many fucking
48 day aged steak restaurants
do you know?
- Sorry I have 45.
(Joey laughing)
That's on the lower
end of age that I have.
- You have the 90 day ate stake.
- I wanna have steak five times a week.
I typically go for the higher end stuff.
- 45 is good.
- I remember the first time we went there,
we were like, they gave us the-
- He does ask every time.
- Yeah. They gave us the
menu and we were just like,
"Uh, can I get this and this please?"
And he's just like,
"You can."
But I wouldn't.
(Joey laughing)
I remember when we first went there,
we were like, "What a rude fucking place?
Telling us how to eat our meal."
And then we got the meal
and we were just like,
"Oh, he was right.
He was recommending us
the good shit." (laughs)
- If the guy is confident enough to like,
"Nah. Don't do it."
- Yeah.
How often do you go to a
restaurant where that happens?
- Never.
- Yeah exactly, right. (laughs)
The absolute audacity, that's the thing.
That's such a big risk
'cause if that risk doesn't,
if this is like not one of
the best meals I've had,
which it was by the way.
- Then it takes some
serious balls to do that.
- But normally in Japan,
it's very common that
you will find restaurants
that are like max eight seating.
And there's only like two staff-
- Yeah.
- And normally to pull off
a restaurant like that,
and make it good requires
a fuck ton of care.
You can't run a two man restaurant,
and it's not be totally shit or amazing.
I feel like it's very
difficult I don't know.
- Yeah. I didn't really appreciate
it until basically later
in life because I grew up with my parents
running a local family restaurant.
And I didn't realize before,
because like to me every
restaurant was run,
like the restaurant
where I grew up in right?
That was the bare minimum.
That was the normal.
I would see my dad really
taking care of the customers
and really talking to them,
getting to know them,
and I could see my mom
in the kitchen as well.
And I cared about her food
so whenever she cooks
something that tasted off.
I was like, "Mom, this is awful.
Like why are you serving
this to the customers?
You can do better mum."
And I was like the worst
fucking critic there,
because it was my mom.
So I could criticize my mom's
cooking 'cause I was like.
- Did she cry?
- "Why mom?"
No she didn't cry.
- I think you were Gordon Ramsey on her.
- You're shit, what is this mum,
this is garbage.
- She didn't cry but I'm pretty
sure whenever I'd say like,
whenever I'd say she
didn't cook a good meal,
like she felt it in her
soul and she's like,
"Oh, I'm gonna do better next time."
- Or she was thinking to
herself, "You little shit."
(Garnt laughing)
The fucking audacity.
- So that's why I like had a high standard
when I go into restaurants.
So that's why it blows my
mind when I go to a restaurant
and I have like a bad experience.
'Cause I'm just like,
"Well, I thought this was
just normal everywhere."
You're running a restaurant.
You're serving food.
If you serve food that's worse
than what you serve at home.
How's that allowed?
How is that legal?
- It should be the norm though.
- Yeah, how is that legal?
- You're paying for their skill.
- Yeah, you're paying
someone to do a service
that you can't do.
So unless you're a fucking chef,
which most of us aren't like
fucking Michelin star chefs.
We don't have enough olive
oil to be Michelin star chefs
most of the time.
- That's true.
- So you go to somewhere else for them
to cook the food for you.
And if it's worse than
what you cook yourself,
then why am I paying you for this meal?
That's just my opinion.
- It was great growing
up in the UK, up north,
the bar's very low for culinary ability.
So literally going
outside of the UK is like,
"Holy shit, stuff tastes great."
Everything.
- What's the best Welsh dish?
- We don't have Welsh dishes.
- Oh.
- We have Welsh cakes.
- What's a Welsh cake?
- I don't know how to describe it.
It's like a-
- A sponge cake or?
- Can you pull it up may be?
- Well it's like this weird
like raisin-esque like pastry,
with some kind of icing on it.
I can't remember.
I never really liked
it, but people loved it.
And then they had
something butter I believe.
- Butter brief?
- Yeah, there was butter I believe.
- What is this?
So that's the Welsh cake?
Is this it?
- Oh, they look like scones.
- Like a pan cake.
- Yeah, they look like scones.
- Wait, was it in pan cakes?
- Wait, was it scones?
I swear there's something else as well.
- You say scones, not the
scones or something like that.
- Well scones.
- Scones.
- Yeah.
- We say scones and I know they're scones.
So I don't know why.
- Scones?
- America?
- They say scones in America?
- No, no, British people say scones.
- Do we say scones?
- Depends with the North or South?
- I've always said scones.
- Yeah, I always say scones.
- Oh.
- When I grew up, I always said scones.
- [Camera Man] Do you
know what that means?
Is it like a specific term?
- Is that something on a hill?
- That's apparently the
name of the Welsh cake.
- Something on a hill.
- We had leek soup. That was a dish.
- Oh, I've seen that honestly.
- What do you call the meal
that you have in the evening?
- Tea.
- What? What!
(Camera Man laughing)
- Fucking Northerners, man.
- There's specific
Australians that call it that.
- I've had to adapt
because nobody understood
what I was saying,
- 'Cause it doesn't make sense.
It doesn't make sense.
- Okay. POV, you wake up in North, UK.
- Yeah.
- You wake up, you have breakfast.
- It hits 12 o'clock you have dinner.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Then it gets to 6:00 PM you have tea.
Not tea the drink, tea the meal.
- Yeah.
- I'll ask my parents what's for tea,
and then they'll tell me.
- Even now?
- Yeah, it's beans on toast.
- I've understood the
tea equals dinner thing.
I've never understood the
dinner equals lunch thing.
That confuses me more.
- Because the point is you
have dinner in your vocabulary
and you just choose not to
put it for fucking dinner.
This is the one thing northerners
and southerners in England
can never fucking agree on.
- When you grow up in the
place in a certain place,
you rarely go to like south England
if you're from north England.
You rarely go to north England
if you're from south England.
- There's the real like
north south divide.
- People travel a lot in
the UK, just out of the UK.
People always, it's sort of 90%.
- It's cheaper a lot of the time.
- Yeah, it's cheaper yeah.
- 'Cause like trains in
England are so expensive.
I remember like there
was this news article
about how two students in like
two different universities,
wanted like two friends from
three different universities
wanted to meet each other.
So they figured out that
flying to fucking Spain,
was cheaper via easy jet was cheaper,
than getting a train to meet each other .
- So if you wanted to go from
London to Wales where I live,
it's a three-hour journey
and it's about 120 bucks,
for a really shit train.
- Oh jeez!
It's not like a Shinkansen
where it's nice,
and you feel comfortable.
There's no outlets,
you're very lucky if you get one.
- Yeah.
- And some of the trains
are horrible as well.
- Yeah, basically like as
a student to go anywhere,
you need to book your train
like three weeks in advance,
get the fucking advanced tickets.
And you better hope that
you get that exact train,
three weeks later.
- And also like you know
the EasyJet and Ryanair
would often have deals where if you flew
without any luggage,
you printed off your boarding ticket,
you could get tickets for like $15,
to some European places.
- Fucking hell!
- So it's like, "Why the
fuck would you ever like go
up north or go down south?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah. That's true.
- So you didn't really interact.
So, naturally I never
really heard people saying,
lunch and dinner for-
- Lunch and dinner.
- But now I say lunch and dinner,
because if I say dinner and tea,
everyone thinks I'm a fucking weirdo.
- But rightly so. Rightly so.
I swear northerners I said it.
- But after like one or two
days of being back in Wales,
I'll start adapting back.
- Assimilating back into the culture.
- I'll become one of them.
(Garnt laughing)
And I'll say, "Yeah so
we say dinner for lunch
and tea for dinner."
But it's weird because
it's like, do you want tea?
But it's like, you understand?
You just know depending
on how it's been said,
or you read the atmosphere.
- The time of the day.
- It's the meal or the cup of tea, right?
- Yeah, you just know.
- Yeah, yeah.
- What if you asked for tea at like seven?
- You just know what's being asked.
(Garnt laughing)
- You would say, can I have some tea?
Can I have tea?
- No, but can I have some
tea you can also mean,
can I have some dinner?
- Someone could be like,
"I'm gonna make tea."
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah what does that mean?
- That could mean a meal
or that could mean a cup.
- Sometimes people say 'cuppa.'
I don't really like the word cuppa.
- A cuppa.
We say that in Australia as well.
- British people say cuppa tea.
- I think I saw one of you tweet about it.
- I've never really
grown on the word cuppa.
I don't know why it's
not really grown on me.
- 'Cause some Australians especially
those that have British parents,
they sometimes say tea for
dinner, even in Australia.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- My people.
- Like I had a few friends
back in high school
who had British parents
obviously from the north,
and yeah, they used to say tea.
And I'm like, "I don't
even drink tea, bro.
Coffee all the way. Fuck off."
(Connor laughing)
And then when I realized they were talking
about like the meal tea,
I was like, "Do you drink
tea with every meal?
Like what does that mean?
How British can you get?"
- My mum, right?
She microwaves bacon.
Isn't that disgusting?
- I know a lot of Americans
that microwave bacon.
- I know a lot of
Americans using microwave
for a lot of things
including boiling water.
- I was just a kid I always
thought I hated bacon,
but I realized I just
hated microwaved bacon.
Because the fat isn't crispy at all.
It's just really soggy.
- It's moist.
- Sydney's dad microwaves eggs,
to make scrambled eggs.
- (gasping) Oh no.
- That's like a war,
that has to go against
the Geneva convention.
(all laughing)
That's a war crime.
- I cook a steak in the microwave.
(all laughing)
- Nowadays though
they're using air fryers.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- We get it Meilyne,
you're obsessed with your air fryer.
- Oh yeah, didn't you fucking
buy an ice cream maker
the other day?
- Oh yeah, I did.
- Don't fucking tell Connor by the way.
- See ice cream is the best dessert right?
- You're right, I should bring
the ice cream maker here.
'Cause I've locked it away.
'Cause I started gaining.
- Yeah, bring it here. Let's do it.
- Honestly I would love
an ice cream maker here.
- Bring it here, we can make
our own espresso affogatos.
- No, no, no.
Yogurt, frozen yogurt
from this baby is so good.
- Just like coffee flavored shit man.
- Yes.
- Like not coffee jelly.
- Okay, here's the thing
I've noticed actually.
So I do love coffee,
I love coffee. It's great.
I love my grand dirt water,
but I have noticed there's
an awful of influx of things
that have coffee flavored
things that are shit,
really shit.
You get like get like coffee
cookies or coffee bread.
And it's just fucking terrible.
- I've never seen those.
- I've never.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Like here?
- Yeah, yeah.
I've had coffee cake, like
coffee cake tastes like shit.
- I like coffee cake, coffee cakes okay.
- No, just get a tiramisu.
- I mean that is a coffee cake.
- But that's not like breaded coffee cake.
- I need to take you to this place,
where it's a $90 espresso.
I had it three days ago.
It was free though.
- $90 expresso?
- Okay. Wait, why was it free?
- My friend is a regular there so.
- Oh, well it's good for good for the-
- Good for level.
- No, no.
- I'm not paying 90 fucking
quid for an espresso.
- Sorry, we're not well-connected
as like the fucking top 5% here.
- You can come with me. (laughs)
- All right.
- Okay, so I go out with
you I get it for free?
Why is it $90?
(Joey laughing)
- I don't know.
- No promises. (laughs)
- I'm just gambling if I'm spending $90.
- And Meilyne's just like, "90 bucks."
- No, you don't say
anything if you're regular,
you show up and then
they pass you the glass,
and it's the black glass
and then they'll like.
- What about it is $90?
- Yeah, what about is $90?
- The way they roast it,
where the beans are sourced.
- Fuck off no.
- Isn't that like expensive coffee
that's made from like that cat poop?
- It's a civet poop, you mean.
- Do you know that?
- The most expensive coffee.
- The most expensive coffee
in the world is made out
of this like wild cat poop.
- It's like a weasel.
- Have you not seen the bucket list?
- No.
- [Camera Man] Kopi Luwak.
- Oh yeah, Kopi Luwak.
That's Malaysian.
- It's like a big plot
point in the bucket list.
- It's like a big
Malaysian wild cat species
that eats coffee beans.
And then they shit out the coffee beans,
and then the stomach acid creates
like the very special
flavor of the coffee beans.
People collect those beans,
wipe off the poop and then
grind it to make coffee.
- Yeah.
- Apparently it's really delicious.
- I've had it. It's actually
really fucking good.
- Is it the best coffee in the world?
- It's pretty up there.
- Is it better than Starbucks? (laughs)
- Obviously not.
- Is it better than the Nespresso?
- Nespresso's in a league of its own.
(Garnt laughing)
- That's readily available.
- Have you watched like
those coffee YouTubers?
- Oh, I can't handle it.
(all laughing)
- It's like it's so fucking pretentious.
- I like to watch it muted.
- Yeah, they're like,
"So I'm gonna make my morning espresso
and they bring out like five
contraptions and it's like,
surely this is just not practical.
Like cleaning this is
just a nightmare surely."
- Yeah.
- Like the reason why I don't
grind my own coffee beans
and do all that it's 'cause the
absolute mess that it makes.
- And it takes so much time.
Like I remember I got an espresso machine
before like the Nespresso.
It actually was a proper espresso machine
where you have to like
grind your beans yourself,
put it in and it made so much fucking mess
and it took so much time.
- Cleaning it is such a bitch.
- Like you're having to
clean the fucking beans
every time you wanna just
make a fucking cup of coffee.
- Yeah. I remember I bought as well one
of those fucking pots
that you put on the stove,
and you put the espresso on the top
and the water on the bottom
and it boils through.
- Yeah, we used to have that at home.
- I could never get that to taste right.
I don't know why.
- It didn't taste good,
'cause it was so hard to
get the balance right.
- Yeah.
- And also cleaning it
was so fucking difficult.
I felt like I was trying to clean
like iron man's heart socket.
My fucking hand couldn't fit in it,
and it never got cleaned.
- You just have a big hand.
- Yeah, as a result you just sewing it.
- And it never got to it.
It was like trying to clean
the inside of a Pringles can.
It was a nightmare.
Like I couldn't get in there,
and it was just terrible,
and then it kept scratching
my stove 'cause it was metal.
And I was like, "Oh fucks sake."
And then it turns out when
you grind coffee beans,
they expire.
No one told me this until I was wondering
why my coffee tastes likes shit.
- It tastes sour.
- This is a sour blend.
(all laughing)
- It's got some bite back to it.
- I drank it for like like three weeks,
like sour ass coffee.
- Holy shit!
- 'Cause I was like,
"Fuck this gourmet stuff."
(Joey laughing)
- You drown it in milk though, right?
- No, no, I was drinking espresso.
And I was like, it
tastes like one of those-
- Like stomach acid.
- Sulfuric acid espresso
but I thought this
is how the Italians do it, fuck.
- Did it affect your digestive system?
- I felt awful every time I did it,
but I thought this was a good espresso.
It's a good espresso.
- Expensive coffee beans.
- And then I looked on the back of this
and it had expired like three months ago.
- Literally drinking what, acid?
- Yeah. Oh God!
- It's terrible.
- Gosh! How often.
- There's so much food stuff though.
Where it's just a whole thing of balance,
versus this is just impractical.
It's making so much mess.
I need so much equipment
versus I just want to eat.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- If you have time though,
if you're just doing it to relax.
The process of it is meditating.
- Feel like it's a hobby.
It has to be a hobby.
- It has to be a hobby.
Why did you look at me?
- I don't know.
(Garnt laughing)
- You know about meditation right?
- The same thing that Connor did.
- That feels racist.
- Are you being monkist right now?
- Monkist? (laughs)
- I feel like you're being monkist.
I feel like you are-
- Monkist.
(all laughing)
- That's like when I said
lollies and I looked at Joey.
- We're just getting fucking slandered.
- Did you just assume
my Zen state right now?
(all laughing)
- That's a type of meditation
where you do something like you clean.
- Yeah.
- Zen does this?
- Like when I was a monk,
we had a special type of meditation
where you walk when you meditate as well.
And it's just cause you just
drown out your mental state
with just a monotonous task or motion.
Are just constant. Right?
I get it. But at the same time,
I'm not always trying
to meditate when I cook.
- Coffee, coffee.
- To when I do something
or when I make something,
like food or drink in order to consume,
I always compare the practicality
and the time it takes,
versus the time I enjoy
what I'm making. Right?
And that's always the
problem with cooking for me.
'Cause the time I take to
prepare some certain dishes,
and to make the food, then eat it,
which is a very very short amount of time
compared to preparing it.
And then I got to wash
it as well afterwards.
- That's the worst part man,
'cause you eat it. Right?
And then you're relaxing.
You're like, "Ah, this is nice.
Fuck I got to clean all this stuff.
God damn! I used the ice cream machine.
It's got like four fucking
spatulas, God damn it!"
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Ice cream machine is very easy.
You just mix it with
water and it's so good.
- You're just bribing him now.
- No, it's so good.
You will know, next week.
- Yeah, next week bring it
and we'll be the testers.
- Maybe I'll get a coffee
machine maybe one day I will.
- There have been times
where I thought about
getting like a proper coffee machine.
- That shit's so expensive though.
- Surely, they just have to clean.
- They go for like fucking 5 grand
for like one of the proper coffee.
- Surely you just have to
clean the metal scooper thing.
Right? That's it?
- No.
- The metal scooper thing no.
- Well no, because you gotta
clean the siphon as well.
- Gotta clean the siphon.
You've gotta clean the milk.
- Oh fuck!
You could just use the
Nespresso thing now.
(Joey laughing)
- Or the milk frother.
- Milk frothers are pretty good.
What do you mean?
I feel like milk frothing
does not need to be done
by 1,000 dollar machine.
Like I'm pretty sure I
could do it with my finger
if I did it fast enough,
you know what I mean?
Like I don't need a machine to do it.
I am the machine.
(all laughing)
- Pretty sure you'd get
bored of that pretty soon.
- You know what is the
worst frothing machine?
worst fucking dessert?
- Go on.
- The macaroons.
- Oh yeah I know.
- Which kind?
- I agree.
- All of them.
They never, ever, ever
taste as good as they look.
- The sugary things right?
- The sugary burger ones.
- Oh yeah, I actually like it.
It's just sugar.
- And in Japan,
they're obsessed with them.
- Yeah.
- They're fucking everywhere.
- Because they're kawaii a.f. dude.
- It was a thing in LA
or SF too for a while.
- I just feel like sometimes,
especially with dessert in Japan.
If it isn't Instagram,
it's not like Instagrammable
it's not a dessert.
- Macaronis for me are like, I eat two,
and I'm like done for the year.
- It just tastes like shit.
- You know what I don't get?
- What?
- Boba.
- I like Boba.
- Why is it so popular?
- That's also like a twice
a year thing for me.
- Boba is just the pumpkin
spice latte of Asia.
I fucking said it. Okay.
I fucking said it.
- It's good.
- It is.
- It's good. It's good.
- It's just milk tea. It's just milk tea.
- But chewy tapioca.
- Sometimes you just want milk
tea and there's nothing like,
why the fuck do you like boba Joey?
Do you know what tapioca is like?
- Shit. I know.
- Jelly.
(Joey laughs)
- No, it's not.
- I don't get the tapioca.
- It's just jelly.
- That's what makes boba, boba.
- You're getting milk tea,
and you're putting jelly in it.
- Yeah.
- I don't like tapioca.
I don't have it.
- Then, you don't like boba then.
- You don't like boba,
you just drink the milk tea.
- You're literally just milk tea.
- I participated, I turn up to the chain.
I Instagram it.
- Just because bought milk
tea from a Boba place.
It doesn't automatically make it boba.
- It's boba.
- It's not boba.
- It's boba guys, come on.
But also the second reason why I love Boba
is 'cause of the hilarious fucking videos
we get out of the
absolute carnage it causes
from people choking on
the fucking tapioca,
to people fucking up stabbing it.
It's an endless supply
of hilarious videos.
- It has nothing to do with Boba.
- It has nothing to do with Boba though.
- No, it is very funny.
- But it's got nothing to
do with you drinking boba.
- No but part of the reason,
one of the reasons I love
it is just the endless
entertainment value.
And I love taking someone
who's never had Boba,
to a Boba place 'cause
they always fucking choke
on the tapioca.
- Who hasn't had Boba
in this day and age?
- Well in Wales, no one's
had fucking tapioca.
- Okay, yeah.
- Northerners! (laughing)
- Watching people drink
tapioca the first time,
'cause you could never,
if you haven't drank tapioca before.
- It goes up the straw very fast.
- Yeah. They struck it
too hard and it just stabs
the back of the throat.
- Because you've never drank anything,
that is like that.
You always drink balls that big.
(all laughing)
Yeah, so whenever you drink it right?
It's always catches you
off guard the first time.
- Yeah.
- So it's very fun watching someone go,
"Oh, this looks good."
(Conner gasping)
(Joey laughing)
- Even someone who's
experienced drinking boba
like knowing that it's coming
and there's like a little like, (laughs)
(all laughing)
- I love that so much.
- Have you ever shot
the boba from the straw?
- The thing I don't get about,
what can I call it? Boba culture.
'Cause I guess there's a
fucking culture around it now.
- Especially in Japan.
- Rise up fellow boba drinkers.
- 'Cause what I don't get is that people,
go out of their way to get boba.
And I'm just like, "Why?"
- It's great.
- I've never understood
especially in Japan
when like couple of years ago
when the Boba craze was huge.
- Yeah.
- Of just like these like
high school kids lining up
for like two hours.
- Oh yeah, it should be fair.
- To get boba I'm like, "What?"
- It's literally milk tea.
Like I get some desserts, I
get some special ice creams,
because there's only like this-
- Ice cream?
- Huh?
- Yeah, honestly.
Ice cream is great dessert.
I didn't say it wasn't great dessert.
I was defending jelly.
- Is it the best dessert?
- It's the way they
cook the tapioca pearls.
- Hold on, I need to get my answer.
- The what?
- Is it the best dessert?
- What is the best dessert?
- I think you cut it.
- Oh my God! (laughs)
- But that doesn't mean
that jelly's a bad dessert.
Jelly's still good.
- Yeah.
- They're so different though.
- Huh?
- Boba and jelly-
- Yeah the jelly texture
is entirely different.
- It's way more chewy. It is.
- I love the chewiness of it.
(Garnt laughing)
- Do you ever wedge them
in between your teeth?
- I don't really eat it that much, so no.
- Oh, okay.
- What is that part of Boba culture
that you have to be like-
- What the fuck?
(all laughing)
- Is that what you need to do
to like assimilate into Boba culture?
- Is that what boba drinkers do?
(all laughing)
- You're just playing
with textures or the food.
I just want to know. How is it?
- Yeah, 'cause like some cuisines,
some desserts, some snacks.
I understand people
going out of their way,
to get to this certain thing.
Boba it's just milk tea.
It's milk tea with a bit of jelly in it.
And I just don't get that.
- It's stimulation in the mouth,
with the chewing.
- You can do that with most foods Meilyne.
- No it's different.
Is there a food that's like
tapioca that same chewiness?
- Jelly.
- Mochi, no, no jelly is soft.
Mochi there's more bite to it.
- I do like mochi actually.
- I'm like on the fence about mochi.
I liked the way it tastes,
but then I also feel like it should come
with a health warning.
'Cause oh my God,
I'm a normal functioning human being,
who knows how to chew their food
and has no problem doing it.
And even I feel like
I'm gonna fucking choke
on a mochi if I chew it wrong.
- A lot of old people
actually die every year.
- I know.
- I feel like mochi
is just gotta like rip it into bits,
and then just eat the bits that you can.
- You have to take small bites out.
- Yeah, you can't just throw
the whole mochi in your mouth.
- Yeah.
- It depends on the mochi.
- Like fucking mouth breathers
should not eat mochi.
(Joey laughing)
- Stop bringing this back.
- You're playing with fire man.
(all laughing)
- 'Cause their nose is congested.
- If your nose is congested
and you eat mochi.
- That's like instant death right there.
- That's instant death right there.
- Pretty sure you can just die anywhere.
- Oh my god, how do mouth
breathers kiss then?
(all laughing)
- Breathe into each other's mouths.
(Joey breathing heavily)
- I don't think they are incapable
of breathing through their nose.
I think it's the default.
- They don't have their
nose chopped off like.
- It's like people who
have Internet Explorer
as their default browser.
It doesn't mean they can't use Chrome,
it's just that they don't all the time.
- They're just at a disadvantage.
- Yeah.
- And they just don't,
it's just slow and consequences happen.
- Like I didn't understand how something
could become like a choking hazard.
Like how food could become a
proper choking hazard until-
- Lego.
- Oh
- Oh yeah.
- No, no, no.
Like as an adult I'm talking,
I understand as a child
that a lot of things
can become choking hazards,
but I didn't understand
it until I went to America
for the first time and had
like my first American steak
where it's like-
- Oh God I know you're in.
- It's not a steak.
It's just a slab of meat at that point.
- Yeah, yeah.
- They like plop it on
and you're just like,
"Wow! I kind of feel like
Hannibal Lecter right now."
I'm like, "Jesus Christ."
And then you just start
chewing into this thing.
And then they're like,
and you start chewing it.
And it's like, it's just a lot of meat.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, yeah.
- This can be taken out of context,
I've never had that much
meat in my mouth at once.
Like just in general. Right?
- Was it too much meat
in your mouth to handle?
- It was a bit too much meat in my mouth.
- It's a bit hard to swallow, wasn't it?
- It was very hard to swallow,
and I'm just like, "Jesus."
Okay, I can understand how
people can choke on steaks now.
- But also if they use like
a really cheap cut of meat.
Yeah, holy fuck!
- It's like chewing on leather.
- It's like a dog talking.
- Sometimes it's good though.
It's like beef flavored gum.
- No.
- What the fuck?
That is the worst stake I've ever had.
What the fuck?
- No, when it's chewy.
- What did you just say?
- Meat flavored gum?
- You're just chewing
and the more you chew,
the more flavors are released.
- But it will not break down.
- Yeah.
- No matter how much you chew,
you cannot get it to separate.
- Beef flavored gum.
- Yeah.
- Holy fuck! What?
- This is like that scene
in the "40 Year Old Virgin"
where like they're describing
the the feel of like breasts.
- It's like a bag of sand.
- It's a fucking bag of sand.
- Oh, I love steak,
I love when it's too chewy
that I can't swallow it.
(Garnt laughing)
- I don't want to experience
a meal where afterwards
my jaw is just like,
ready to fall off my face.
- Meilyne, I got you, it's
a meat flavor tapioca.
(Joey laughing)
- There's a restaurant in Japan.
And it's like a chain called,
what is it like Ikinari steak or-
- Ikinari Steak.
- Ikinari Steak?
- Yeah.
- It's fucking abhorrent steak.
So I went there.
And yeah I went with a friend,
and we both order it.
And I was like steak in
Japan is quite expensive
to get a good steak.
- Yeah.
- And they bought the cheapest steak,
but which also had the option
to have the biggest size out
of any of the steak.
So none of the other
steaks were like 300 grams.
- Right yeah.
- For some reason this one
stake that was super cheap.
- Yeah sirloin or something?
- It was called like it,
but it was named something
like man meat or something.
- Man meat?
(Joey laughing)
- It was like something
supposed to be manly.
(all laughing)
And it was called monster
meat or something.
- (laughs) That's even worse.
- No joke, it was called
like monster cut meat.
And I was like, "What the fuck is that?"
So I was like, the sirloin
you get about half the meat.
It's about double the price.
I'm sticking with the sirloin,
'cause I frankly wanna enjoy my meal.
So we're eating and they're
like the first piece.
They're like, "Shit, this is quite tough."
I'm hearing them chewing,
chewing, chewing, chewing.
And I'm like, "You good?"
And they're like, "It's
just really hard to eat."
They managed to eat one
bite and then I felt bad.
So I was like, "Yeah, do you
wanna have we'll trade pieces?"
So I gave them two pieces of mine
and I took two pieces of theirs.
So I felt bad 'cause it was terrible.
- Yeah.
- I nearly fucking choked,
on how bad the steak
was 'cause you literally
couldn't break it apart.
- Yeah. You literally can't.
- It's such shit meat.
- And it takes so much
effort that you have
to start breathing through
your mouth in order
to like get the air.
- When you get to that point
where you're chewing meat
so much that you're like,
"Have I gotten this meat blob,
into a size that I think
is okay to swallow?"
- Yeah.
- Because I don't think
I can break it down.
- Yeah.
- Why don't you just cut
a smaller piece?
- It's not soft enough
to go down.
- Is it soft enough
that I won't chock.
- And it's just like
one is that soft enough
that you don't choke in too
sometimes you just cut off
like a bit too big of a piece.
It doesn't break down enough
and you just have to like,
pray to God that your
esophagus can just squeeze
this fucking meat part down.
- That absolute rookie error.
We took out take out and
we had plastic forks.
- Oh no!
- There we go.
- There was absolutely no chance
that we could 'cause the
stake already pre-cut it
into like pieces like this.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Which is like too much.
- These pieces of meat from
this cow that I assume was just
benching all the other cows.
I don't know what the fuck was going
on with this cow to have meat that-
- That boy was ripped.
- The FDA was probably testing all
the fucking drugs on this cow.
- Doing some roids or something.
- It was insane how
muscular this cow was like.
- They have good cuts there
though, Ikinari steak.
- The sirloin steak
that was like this big,
was like $30.
- Yeah.
- It was terrible.
- In which case you better off going
to like a higher end steak.
- Yeah, and the only reason I went there
was because everything else was closed.
It was the only place to get take out.
- They're open pretty late.
- What did you expect from a place
that's literally called 'Suddenly Steak'.
- Yes. Suddenly steak.
- Is that what it's called?
- Surprise, steak!
- Suddenly steak.
(all laughing)
- No, it's meant to be a cheaper version.
- It's kinda like Japanese food in the UK.
It's like I'm not expecting much.
- Yeah.
- I didn't go in there
expecting a good steak.
It's like the same I didn't
expect good steak to be in Japan
because Japan doesn't really have,
Japan imports most of their normal steak.
- Yeah.
- In terms of like steak steak.
Japan's steak isn't great.
- They import nearly all of their steak,
that isn't like the Kobe.
- Yeah, like Australia.
- Australia and America.
- Ireland, as well.
- Yeah, so generally
beef here is quite bad
unless it's like Kobe beef
but I get sick of kobe beef.
- We've talked about this previously.
Do you know what I miss?
That I found is like
apparently only in Europe.
Peppercorn sauce.
- Oh.
- Yes.
It's this amazing steak sauce.
- It's like the best
steak sauce I've ever had.
I know peppercorns.
- And you only get it with soup.
- It's like a creamy
literal peppercorn sauce.
I thought it was like a universal thing
because in England you have steak,
you have it with peppercorn sauce,
and it tastes so fucking good.
And then I only realized
moving out of England,
even though other places in
the world have like better
quality meats like Japan or America,
they have like the better quality meats.
Than a lot of the steaks
you can find in the UK,
but it's just-
- What the fuck are you going?
Where are you going?
- I'm in Brighton,
there's not a great steak
in Brighton honestly.
- There's so many good stuff
you're missing out Garnt.
- Maybe, but like the peppercorn sauce
would always save that
steak for me because,
the two of them just
tasted so good together.
And like it's something
that you just don't find
elsewhere in the world
apart from in Europe.
Apparently that's the
only place I've found.
- I swear I've seen it in
some restaurants in America.
I don't know though. Maybe I have.
- Your steak is mid comment.
I didn't properly get
until I realized that,
every steak here is we
have salt and pepper.
And I'm just like-
- And wasabi which I just
don't think is good on steak.
- I think Wasabi good on steak.
- It depends on the cut.
- It depends on the fatty-
- There's only so much.
- Soy sauce?
Some of them have like Garnt soy sauce.
- Oh God, actually it's different.
It's like, if it's yakiniku,
then yeah I'll have it.
- Well, yeah if it's
yakiniku then that's good.
But that's not usually steak.
- That's not a steak.
- I have a steak, and every steak here.
Every steak I've had in Japan
and most of the places I've had,
I've been in America as well.
You have the option of salt and pepper
or in America you have Adju,
which is I think it's just-
- What is adju.
- This liquid that comes out of the meat.
- Yeah. It's just the meat juices.
- It's just the meat meat sauce.
- Well they pour it back on?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah.
My dad used to do that.
(Connor laughs)
- Good the lore's here.
They have a Lori's.
And I'm just like there's so
many different steak sauces
out there like peppercorn
and red wine sauce as well,
which goes fucking amazing with steak
and nobody does that.
And I'm just like, "Why, why?"
I guess steak tastes good but
there's only so many times
I can have salt and pepper on steak.
- In the UK there's steak with ketchup.
- Do they
- Yeah.
- A1 I could understand,
it's kind of ketchupy.
- I like A1.
- We didn't have A1
in Australia.
- We got in the UK.
- What's wrong with you
guys, why'd you do that?
This is why everyone comes to us.
- Listen, everyone mocks me.
And British people for
growing up with this
but you don't understand.
We're truly overpowered.
We have literally no benchmark for food.
(Joey laughing)
It is so shit that when I go-
- It's the world western food out there.
- I literally go anywhere and I'm like,
"Fuck this shit the busing.
And it's got like cockroaches in it."
And I'm like, "Damn this shit is so good!"
- I appreciate the bossing.
- I think I can do you one worse,
because I think in Thailand
they eat pizza with ketchup.
- I'm okay with that.
- What kind of ketchup?
- Are you okay with that?
- Tomato puree, tomato ketchup,
- It's just a normal pizza.
- Like a cheese pizza?
- Yeah.
- What other kind of pizza is there?
- I don't know, like
pepperoni or fucking Hawaiian.
- I'm gonna be honest. If I'm at my house,
I put tomato ketchup on the side
and I dunk the crusts in it.
- Yeah, I do that.
- That makes sense.
- Yeah that's good.
- I did the mayonnaise
and ketchup combination.
- I don't need to do that.
(all laughing)
How do you make to do that?
- How do you feel about
Brazilian barbecue?
- I fucking love Brazilian barbecue.
- Yeah, Brazilian barbecue is great.
- Their sauces.
- That's what we can finally agree on.
(all laughing)
Oh my God! all of Trash
Taste's agreeing on food.
- Thank you Brazil.
- You finally made us agree on something.
- Who knew that Brazilians
could bring about world peace?
(all laughing)
- I remember 'cause the first
time I had it was in Japan.
'Cause I had a Brazilian in my class,
and they were like, "Oh,
come to our barbecue,
we're having one."
And apparently there's
a place in Yokohama,
no Tokyo Bay.
There's like fields where
you can rent a tent spot
right next to the Tokyo water.
- Like a picnic spot?
- Yeah. And I think they
provide the barbecue,
and you just bring your own meat.
She was a food scientist or something.
Somebody like designed food or something.
- A nutritionist of some kind?
- Something of that.
And then she was like,
"You have to come, come try."
And I was like, "I guess I'll show up."
And they had like just amazing food.
It was so good. The sausage was amazing.
I love sausage.
- Food scientist.
- Gastronomy you're right.
That's the word.
- I don't know.
Something like people would pay her,
and she said that she would go to a place,
like a chain or whatever.
And then she would tell them
how to make the food better,
with science or something.
- Yeah, with science.
- With science.
- Why didn't you introduce me to her?
(all laughing)
- Meilyne's just like frothing at her.
The food scientist?
- Like every single item at
this barbecue was amazing.
- Yeah.
- It was like everything
was like pre-seasoned
before it went on and then I
was like, "I feel very happy."
- You gotta love the preseason.
- So I turned up, ate their food.
And then I was like,
"Yeah, I've got to go now."
But actually had to go I
couldn't stay for long.
- Yeah.
- But I had as much as I could.
- Fair enough.
- I remember like the
geeks plus opening party
that we went to which you unfortunately
was not.
- Fuck!
- 'Cause you were at the country awards.
I remember the food there was so still.
I still remember it to this day
'cause it was like so unique.
- Yeah, it's innovative cuisine.
- 'Cause they booked out like it wasn't
like a two-star Michelin restaurant.
- They actually invested into a Michelin.
Well not, they didn't
invest into a Michelin.
They invested in a innovative restaurant,
that got two stars after
like a year and a half
of research and opening.
(Joey laughing)
I had chipotle in my boxer shorts.
- No but that restaurant is called Inuwa.
Sadly because of coronavirus
it closed forever.
They were very particular about the meat.
They don't serve chicken, beef or pork.
No normal meats.
- And they don't serve the big three.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
They don't serve the big three.
- They don't serve that normal shit here.
- They have deer.
It has to be a special deer
that's hunted in a specific way.
And depending on where it's
shot and the side it falls
and the blood flow affects the meat.
- Okay, now that just seems
to be a little too much.
- That's a bit wanker ish.
- No, no, it's true.
- What are they going to do call it?
Where did you shoot it?
Where did you shoot it? Tell me.
- In which way did the blood flow,
did it flow uphill or did it
flow upstream or downstream?
- Which way was the wind
blowing as you shot it?
- I just find it hard to believe
that that could really
affect it that much.
- It does, 'cause the blood cells rupture
and then it contaminates
the meat where you shot.
- It's the same with fish as well.
- Yeah, same with fish.
Same with fish, yeah.
- Fish is like one of the
most sensitive meats I think,
because you can tell when
you've had all the fish.
- Other than human.
(all laughing)
- What?
- I said other than human.
- No, because like you can tell
when you have fresh fish,
you can tell when it's
been in the freezer.
- Frozen fish is like instant like ugh.
You can immediately tell.
- You can immediately
tell from like the texture
and the taste and everything.
- Well, like if you
freeze a piece of chicken.
- Well I'm sad 'cause Japan ruined fish.
Just now I can't eat frozen fish.
Cause now I know where-
- I never could eat frozen fish.
- Yeah because that's all
that's all we really ate.
- 'Cause you couldn't get fresh.
- That's why I hated fish in the UK.
- It's always frozen.
- Yeah 90% of the time it's frozen.
And I just think it tastes,
you can taste the
frowziness and that's just
the bland, frozen taste of fish that just,
every person UK has grown up with.
And that's why I hated fish
until I moved to Japan right?
- Where 90% of it is fresh.
- Yeah. Because unless you
actually went to a UK restaurant
where actually shopped in a fish market,
to get fresh fish and even then,
you better go into the day
on the day that they went
to the fish market. Right?
- Yeah.
- That's why if you go
to eat you have to eat
on like only on like Mondays basically.
'Cause that's that's
when they mostly go shop,
for the fresh fish from the fish market
and by Friday it's all like old.
- Yeah.
- So yeah. That sounds horrible.
- Isn't your city though, near the port?
- See, that's a good question.
'Cause the UK is an island.
Yeah. We don't eat fucking fish.
(Joey laughs)
We can it and we fry it. That's about it.
- Yeah.
- Why is it only fried?
- Yeah some people grill it,
grilled fish isn't that common in the UK.
- I think fried fish you can
kind of hide the freshness,
a little more than if
it was just like made.
- Put it in butter, deep fry it.
- The butter hides the fact
that it was probably frozen.
- It's a shame really 'cause I think
a lot of British people didn't like fish.
I grew up loving even like canned fish,
like mackerel and sardines.
I loved.
- I hated that.
- I love canned mackerel.
Canned mackerel is so good.
- With Baguette?
- Oh yeah. You can just
put it on like toast.
- Is it the tomatoly kind?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh yes.
- I love that.
- That shit's great.
- You can just eat it
right out of the can,
you can put it on staff.
It's so good as well.
- That is good.
- 'Cause it's like-
- It's so good as well 'cause it's like
one pound for like I a can.
In Aldi, it was like 60 pence for a can.
And when I was trying to lose weight,
that was great because it's just fish.
- I thought you used broccoli and chicken.
- Yeah. But sometimes
you have to mix it up.
- You gotta switch it up
a little bit. (laughs)
- For lunch, I'd mix it
up with like omelets.
I do like that.
- Okay.
- How long have we been talking for?
If feels like forever.
- [Camera Man] We've been recording 2:25.
- What the fuck!
- What!
- It's been a while.
- Have we been talking for that long?
- We spoke about food for
like an hour and a half.
Fuck my life!
- It was like 9:30.
- Hope you guys enjoyed "Trash Taste."
- Holy fucking shit!
I just feel like we just,
we've been talking for an hour.
What the fuck's going on.
- Thank you so much,
thank you for listening to us.
- I guess we should probably end it.
- Follow Meilyne on
Twitter, @GourmetMeilyne.
Gourmetmeilyne.
- I think it's Gourmetmeil. (laughs)
- Gourmetmeil.
- Her feature YouTube
channel where she speed
runs all the restaurants in Japan.
- That's a great name.
- How can you not call it GourmetMeil?
Or something along those lines.
You come up with so many shitty puns
when I'm with you and you refused.
- Shitty puns?
- Yes. Yes.
- Yeah.
- what's a shitty pun?
- Everything that's not GourmetMeil.
(all laughing)
- That's a great username.
- I may call for like all
the viewers to follow you.
- I can't wait till we go
to our next anime convention
and you actually get
recognized because you used
to be just the book walk
of run around there.
- I used to manage your guys' lines.
- Yeah, you used to manage our line.
- I still will. I still will.
- But now you're gonna
have people being like,
"Are you Gourmetmeil from "Trash Taste?"
Maker of the boys?
- I would start sweating a lot.
(Garnt laughing)
- I'm sweating all the time,
so don't worry about it.
- I know.
- You know? Fuck!
- I watch.
- I smell bad.
- You watch what?
- I watch every bit of sweat roll down.
- Let's get on with the-
- Let's get the patreons.
- Look at these patrons right here.
- If you'd like to support
us though on Patreon,
then go to patreon.com/TrashTaste.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your names on the subreddit
and if your add us
listen to us on Spotify.
And also go check out Meilyne.
oh, I think they're gonna
be gone by the time-
- They're gonna be long gone by the time.
- Hope you got your mugs.
(all laughing)
- I hope you got your mugs.
- To the fellow mug holders.
- If you're watching this
right now and you've got a mug,
pull them out right now.
This is the moment
you've been waiting for.
- Now whip them out.
(all laughing)
- Take a mugshot.
- Shut the fuck up.
- [Camera Man] Oh my God! (laughs)
- See you guys.
- Bye bye, see you bye bye.
(bright upbeat music)